Erinnert ihr euch noch an CVC, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer? Ja, das waren die, die damals bei der Bundesliga einsteigen wollten. Turns out, jetzt haben sie Refinanzierungsprobleme und mussten sich selber Investoren reinholen für ihr Sportgeschäft. Was heißt das und was geht überhaupt so im Bereich der Investoren im Fußball? Darüber wollen wir jetzt sprechen mit Christoph Neßhöfer vom Manager Magazin und Jannik Tillar von Kapital und Stern. Und los geht's.
Das muss man jetzt mal so zur Kenntnis nehmen, damit ist das Projekt beendet.
Für mich, das sage ich ganz klar, ist das eine Niederlage der Zentralfamilie.
Dabei sollte uns bitte die nächste Zeit niemand mehr irgendwie mit Solidaritätsthemen kommen, denn solidarischer, wie wir uns hier aufgestellt hatten, gerade die großen Klubs, solidarischer kann man nicht mehr sein.
Dann im Nachgang beleidigte Leberwürste, sich in der Pressekonferenz dann auch hinzusetzen, also ganz ehrlich, das ist auch nicht in Ordnung, wenn man einer solchen großen Verantwortung gerecht werden will. Ein Thema und jede Menge Nachspielzeit.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ich konnte nicht anders. Ich musste nochmal die beleidigten DFL-Leberwürste hier ins Intro packen. Ihr habt es natürlich gemerkt, das ist das alte Intro, das wir rund um unsere Investoreneinstiegsfolgen schon gemacht haben. Ihr müsst jetzt rausfinden, was damals passiert ist. Aber ich glaube, so grob erinnert ihr euch noch. Schön, dass ihr hier seid und schön, dass meine Gäste hier sind. Christoph Neßhöver, schön, dass du wieder im Rasenfunk bist. Hallo.
Vielen Dank, Max. Freue mich sehr. Hallo.
Und Jannik Tillar ist hier. Hi, Jannik.
Hi, Max. Danke für die Einladung. Freue mich.
Ich freue mich auch, denn wie schon bei der letzten Sendung, die wir gemeinsam hatten, wo wir so die Investorensicht auf den möglichen Einstieg in der DFL besprochen haben, glaube ich, dass es mal wieder Sinn ergeben könnte, über Investoren im Fußball zu sprechen, weil ihr eben auch da einen ganz anderen Blick habt. Und das, was ich im Intro angesprochen habe, das will ich noch mal kurz für die Hörerinnen und Hörer zusammenfassen, das ging ja sehr schnell. Also wir haben mit CVC einen Private Equity Anbieter gehabt, also jemand, der investiert in Unternehmen unter anderem und dann versucht, damit sehr, sehr viel Geld zu verdienen. Spoiler, das machen diese Private Equity Unternehmen auch. Deswegen gibt es sie. Und CVC, die waren damals der Favorit in der Rolle, um auch bei der Bundesliga einzusteigen. Das hat dann nicht geklappt. Wo sind sie eingestiegen? Unter anderem La Liga und in der Liga, aber auch im Damen-, im Frauentennis. Sie sind auch eingestiegen in der indischen Cricket Liga, in der Rugby League. Also sie haben verschiedene Sportinvestments getätigt. Und da haben sie allerdings ein Problem gehabt, nämlich Refinanzierung war da ein Thema. Im Grunde hat eigentlich nur La Liga Geld abgeworfen, so 300 Millionen US-Dollar im Jahr. Komme ich später nochmal zu den genaueren Zahlen. Deswegen hat CVC seine ganzen Sportbeteiligung in ein eigenes Unternehmen ausgelagert und ist auf Investoren-Suche gegangen, um da jemanden zu finden, der ihnen eben hilft bei dieser Refinanzierung. Sie sind losgezogen mit einer Bewertung dieses Sportgeschäfts von 14 Milliarden US-Dollar. Sie haben auch Investoren gefunden, allerdings nach vielen Monaten und nur zu einer Bewertung von 7 Milliarden US-Dollar. Christoph, wenn du magst, dass du mal beginnen, wie bewertest du denn das, was da bei CVC passiert ist?
Naja, sagen wir mal so, auf den ersten Blick ist natürlich keine besondere Erfolgsgeschichte. Das ist klar, wenn man sich die Bewertung anschaut und wie das eingebrochen ist, ist das für CVC jetzt nicht unbedingt ein super Fall oder Beispiel für, dass die gut geplant haben. Muss man natürlich aber auch sehen, diese Private Equity-Unternehmen oder Konzerne, die sind ja riesig groß, die leben ja davon, dass sie in alle möglichen Branchen reingehen und streuen. Die müssen ihr Geld ganz breit, ganz möglichst weit verteilen, damit sie am Ende auf diese Renditen kommen, die sie ihren Kunden versprechen. Und da ist es relativ normal, dass nicht alles funktioniert. So der Sport ist lange so als als Markt gesehen worden von vielen Investoren, als besonders interessant. Warum? Weil er relativ stabil gewachsen ist. Ich habe jetzt mal ganz generell Sport, nicht speziell Fußball erst mal. Und vor allem, weil es eine sogenannte Vermögensanlageklasse, eine Asset-Klasse ist, die als relativ unabhängig gilt von anderen Einflüssen. Also, das wächst mehr oder weniger relativ stabil, ohne egal, was in der Weltwirtschaft so passiert. Und deswegen sind diese Private-Acquities da stark reingegangen, weil die natürlich, weil die immer noch irgendwas suchen, was stabil wächst, damit ich irgendwann, wenn ich dann verkaufe, eine Wertsteigerung habe und dass ich das mit einer relativ hohen Sicherheit versprechen kann. So, das klappt natürlich nicht in jedem Fall. Und in dem Fall klappt es offenbar nicht. Man darf aber auch nicht vergessen, das letzte Punkt noch, dass die natürlich, wenn die am Anfang in so ein Projekt gehen, natürlich die Bewertung so hochpusten, damit es kolossal aussieht, Investoren begeistert und Investoren anzieht. Und natürlich auch die Partner, also beispielsweise jetzt La Liga oder wie auch immer das ist, dass man die beeindrucken kann. Man sagt, ja so groß ist das Geschäft und das versprechen wir euch. Das heißt, ein Stück weit hat es bisher nicht so funktioniert wie die wollten offensichtlich. Ein Stück weit ist aber auch einfach nur Luft rausgelassen worden, die man da so, wie man mal, routinemäßig in dieser Branche da reinpumpt. Weil diese Typen haben schon ein extrem großes Ego und das haben sie gemein mit manchem Fußballmanager und manchem Fußballstar.
Ja, sehr schön zusammengefasst. Jannik, deckt sich das auch so mit deiner Einschätzung?
Ja, grundsätzlich auf jeden Fall voller Zustimmung erstmal für Christoph. Ich würde trotzdem noch sagen, dass diese Korrektur, nennen wir sie mal von 14 auf 7 Milliarden, ist schon sehr deutlich. Also auch jetzt über Gebühr, würde ich sagen. Also man kann da, wenn man will, schon einen ersten kleineren Realitätscheck für den Sport als Investmentmarkt ableiten. Ich glaube das halt auch, weil eigentlich Private Equity so als gesamte Anlageklasse zuletzt ganz gut gelaufen ist. Also die Fonds haben grundsätzlich erstmal viele neue Investoren gefunden, neue Rekorde geschrieben und wenn CVC, wie in diesem Fall, das eben nicht mehr so gelingt, dann spricht das auch von einer gewachsenen Skepsis beim Thema Sport. Und CVC hatte eben eigentlich auch ein ganz gutes Jahr bzw. sie hatten sogar ein Rekordjahr. Also wenn da das Sportportfolio nicht läuft, dann ist das vielleicht tatsächlich ein erstes Anzeichen dafür, dass man das Ganze ein bisschen kritisch unterfragt, was aber auch auf Christoph ein bisschen einzahlt.
Ich meine, die Frage ist natürlich auch, wie hat vielleicht dann CVC zu breit gestreut? Also CVC war der First Mover, wie man sagt. Also die ersten, die mit einer Sportbeteiligung an einem Wettbewerb, vor allem mit der Formel 1, sehr, sehr viel Geld verdient haben. Inzwischen sind sie aber bei Leibn nicht mehr der einzige Investor, der das so macht. Wir haben ja über verschiedene Kandidaten auch damals gesprochen im Tribünengespräch. Dementsprechend ist ja der Markt auch kleiner geworden, weil das ist ja das Interessante am Sportmarkt. Er wächst nicht exponentiell. Es kommt vielleicht mal eine neue Sportart wie Peddeltennis mit dazu, aber da bist du dann drin oder draußen und dann ist es aber auch wieder vorbei. Und an den großen Töpfen verändert sich eigentlich im Grunde sehr wenig. Also wir haben Fußball, wir haben die US-Sportarten, wir haben die Formel 1. Dann hört es schon relativ schnell auf und dementsprechend ist es dann doch irgendwie ein geschlossener Markt innerhalb eines offenen Marktes. Ich fand es interessant, noch mal zu sehen. Also die Financial Times, die hat das auch bewertet als ein Akt, dass man versucht, mit dieser Auslagung des Sportgeschäftes in ein eigenes Unternehmen, also das ist die GST, Global Sports Group, so haben sie es genannt letztlich, dass man damit schlechtere Investments innerhalb dieser Sportsparte verschleiern wollen würde. Also da wird zum Beispiel Rugby genannt, also die Rugby-Liga, die wurde hart von Covid getroffen. Es sind drei der 13 Teams insolvent gegangen. Deshalb wurde da jetzt der Abstieg abgeschaffen, damit die Vereine nicht mehr insolvent gehen müssen. Also so viel zum Thema, wie greift dann so ein Investor vielleicht dann doch ein in eine Sportliga. Aber die Ligue 1, auch aus dem Fußballbereich, die ist ja ein prominenter Fall dafür, dass ein Investment richtig schiefgegangen ist. Da ist alles im Grunde kollabiert. Und jetzt muss man aus den Trümmern was Neues aufbauen. Die Vereine wurden verkauft, aber da kommen wir später noch mit dazu. Also Christoph, wie denkst du darüber nach, dass wir eben hier so einen Sonderfall haben? Es ist eben nicht eine offene Branche, sondern letztlich haben wir ja eine relativ klar definierte Anzahl von Assets. Da hat sich CVC jetzt dann vielleicht das ein oder andere mehr zu viel gekauft, muss man so sagen. Und wie kommen sie aus der Nummer jetzt wieder raus?
Wie sie rauskommen ist, indem sie einfach verkaufen und das Geld woanders anlegen. Das ist jetzt für die nicht so ein Riesenproblem. Aber ich wollte nochmal vielleicht, du hast jetzt ja gesagt, die haben es halt breit gestreut. Klar, die gehen in eine Branche, in den Ball Sport und dann sagen die, okay, Risiko streuen, Risiko streuen. Also und natürlich auch die Chancen optimal nutzen, die vielleicht auch in kleineren Bereichen gibt. Also gehen sie in verschiedene Sportarten rein. Vom Volumen sagt natürlich aber Fußball mit Abstand das Größte. Und wenn man jetzt, ich habe mir jetzt mal kürzlich noch mal angeguckt, die UEFA macht ja jedes Jahr im Herbst, so ähnlich wie die DFL auch, so einen großen Bericht über die großen ganzen Clubs, das sind bei den 700 irgendwas und die legen praktisch alle Zahlen öffnander und gucken sich die generellen Trends an. Da wird natürlich auch immer ein bisschen breit interpretiert, aber nicht, dass wir trotzdem ein paar Sachen schon interessant. Und ein Punkt, den ich interessant fand, weil das nämlich ein bisschen die Luft rausnimmt aus diesem Glauben der Private Equity Leute, dass der Fußball, ich würde nicht sagen, exponentiell wechselt, wie du es gesagt hast, aber sehr stabil immer größer wird, ist, wenn man sich anguckt, welche Einnahmen, Namekategorien haben besonders stark zugenommen in den letzten sechs, sieben, acht, ich glaube, die gehen uns immer auf acht oder zehn Jahre, macht die UEFA das. Und da sieht man, dass gerade dieser Teil Medienerlöse, der diese Fantasie sehr stark getrieben hat, dass gerade im Fußball es immer größer wird, dass der gar nicht so stark gestiegen ist in den letzten zehn Jahren im Vergleich zu anderen Einnahme-Strömen, also Stadion-Einnahmen haben stark zugenommen, ja, viel stärker als die Medien. Anteilich, klar, der Medienmarkt ist immer noch sehr groß, aber mittlerweile gar nicht mehr das Größte, weil das einfach nicht mehr so stark wächst. Das haben wir ja bei den letzten Ausschreibungen international gesehen. Dass es sehr schwierig war für die Ligen, höhere Preise durchzusetzen oder überhaupt höhere Preise zu setzen, geschweige denn Steigerungsraten zu erreichen, die man in der Vergangenheit hatte bei diesen vier Jahreskontrakten. Das heißt, der Markt hat sich schon auch verändert und diese Einstiege der Private-Equities, die Private-Equities gehen dann rein, wenn die davon ausgehen können, dass sie innerhalb von ungefähr fünf Jahren eine relativ starke Wertsteigerung haben. Die setzen ja nicht drauf, dass sie während der Zeit Geld verdienen eigentlich. Deswegen war das, was man gesagt hat, was du gesagt hattest zu La Liga, die haben da ein bisschen Geld verdient aus den laufenden Geschäften, aber darum geht es eigentlich normalerweise gar nicht. Es geht immer darum, Wertsteigerungen erzeugen des Vermögenswertes an sich und dann verkaufen, weil dann kriegst du viel höhere Gewinnmargen, als wenn du da jedes Jahr fünf oder zehn Prozent, sag ich mal, rausziehst. Und das war sehr stark getrieben durch diese Medienrechte, ich will nicht sagen Blase, aber durch diese Steigerungen. Und das ist vorbei, schon seit ein paar Jahren vorbei. Und diese kleineren Branchen, die einen kleineren Sport anbringen, das eh nicht. Das heißt, wenn das über den Fußball nicht kommt, dann gibt es natürlich noch ein paar andere Möglichkeiten, da Geld zu verdienen für die Clubs und für die Ligen. Aber im Endeffekt ist das der Treiber gewesen und den gibt es nicht mehr. Oder den gibt es in der Form nicht mehr. Und da kann man sich jetzt überlegen, sind die vielleicht zu spät eingestiegen, CVC? Weil man muss ja auch sehen, dass noch der Punkt vielleicht, die Private Equities sind ja auch nicht so viel klüger als alle anderen. Die steigen oft erst dann ein. Die steigen oft, ja, die sind man nicht selber frei, sagen die was anderes. Aber das heißt, die steigen schon immer oft erst dann ein, wenn genug Leute sagen, das ist cool. Also die sind nicht früh am Start. Ja, ich meine, wann haben die Reichen sich Clubs gekauft? Das hat ja schon vor 20 Jahren angefangen und länger. Die haben ja auch ein Stück, nicht nur, aber ein Stück weit auch daran geglaubt, sie können da riesig Geld verdienen. Und da ist kein CVC da eingestiegen. Und die haben es erst gemacht, aber haben es jetzt einfach ein bisschen zu spät gemacht. Ich würde gleich noch etwas erzählen, aber vielleicht mache ich jetzt mal Schluss. Das ist so ein beides Beispiel, wie ein Private Equity-Unternehmen in Deutschland Erfahrungen gesammelt hat. Aber das wäre so mein Blick. Also ich glaube, die sind immer so spät eingestiegen ein bisschen. Und man darf nicht vergessen, Fußball ist mit Abstand, das war der größte Wert in diesem Portfolio. Alles andere ist Rugby, ist Kleckerkram, sag ich mal. Von den Volumina. Das passt dann dazu und die finden das cool. Und bei bestimmte Dinge ist das vielleicht für die sinnvoll. Aber insgesamt ist es wirtschaftlich, ist es für so ein Private Equity ehrlich gesagt irrelevant laut Bartennis. Ich glaube nicht, dass das wirklich ein zentraler Punkt war an dieser Strategie.
Ja, es ist interessant, weil wenn man sich nämlich deren Geschäftsberichte durchliest und CVC, also jetzt das Gesamtunternehmen CVC, hat seine Jahreszahlen mit einem Cricket-Bild veröffentlicht vorne drauf. Also da spielt das dann schon eine große Rolle. Und da ist es dann auch einer ihrer Cases, den sie zeigen. Aber da ist mir eben auch schon aufgefallen, wenn du das vergleichst mit anderen Fallstudien, die in solchen Jahresberichten auftauchen, dann sind die Erlöse da eigentlich gar nicht so groß. Da hat man eher so das Gefühl, Sport ist halt so ein Thema, an das alle irgendwie emotional andocken können. Und darum geht es ja auch so. Jahresberichte sind ja auch ein bisschen Marketing für das eigene Unternehmen. Aber Jannik, was sind denn deine Gedanken zu dem, was Christoph gesagt hat?
Ja, ein bisschen Marketing ist gut. Eigentlich ist das ganze Thema nur großes Marketing. Also letztlich stimme ich Christoph da auch wieder um zu. Das ist letztlich diese Lesart, dass CVC insbesondere Sport- oder Sportmedienrechte mit Tech-Multiples bewertet hat. Also gesagt, es hat hier exponentielles Wachstum. Wir möchten so und so viel Prozent jährlich erreichen. Jetzt ist aber so, dass Investoren Sport eher so als eine Art Infrastrukturinvestment bewerten. Zumindest zeigt sich das jetzt auch an dieser Korrektur, an dieser gescheiterten Finanzierungsrunde. Ich würde das irgendwie noch ein bisschen ergänzen und sagen, dass der Markt quasi gesagt hat, wir glauben euch diese Story nicht mehr und wollen deshalb so ein bisschen raus. Ich würde sagen, das ist letztlich das, was dahinter steckt, aber Christoph hat schon das Wesentliche so zusammengefasst. Ich bin gespannt auf Christophs Beispiel in Deutschland.
Das wollen wir jetzt als Erstes hören.
Die Private Acquities, wie ich ja gesagt habe, die sind schlauer als die anderen, aber schon clever. Und die haben sich natürlich, wenn sie sich so eine neue Branche angucken, die sie nicht kennen, auch keine Leute, die sich da auskennen. Das ist bei Private Equity auch immer ganz wichtig, dass die Leute kriegen, die die Branche wirklich verstehen. Die kaufen die ganz teuer ein, versprechen denen dann so einen Anteil an, dem sie gerne gewinnen. Da kannst du ein unglaubliches Geld verdienen, wenn du das schaffst, aber du musst eben die Branche kennen und denn die kann man nicht sporten. Und was war zumindest aus meiner Recherche, was war der Grund dafür, dass KKR, das ist ein ganz anderer, ein anderer sehr großer Private Equity Player, einer der größten, also Colbert Kravitz-Jobbers aus den USA, bei Härte eingestiegen ist damals. Der Grund war, dass die überlegt haben, ist das ein interessantes Asset in der Fußball? Und dann haben die gesagt, könnte sein. Das war ja noch zu einer Zeit, als die Wachstumsraten in den Medienvermarktung noch höher waren. Und wir wollen das kennenlernen. Und der Hintergrund damals war, so habe ich mir das zumindest erzählen lassen, dass KKR gesagt hat, wir müssten das kennenlernen, wir steigen mal bei einem Club ein. Und dann lernen wir die Branche kennen. Und dann lernen wir die Leute kennen. Und dann lernen wir jetzt, wie das zusammen funktioniert. Und für Hertha, ehrlich gesagt, wo ich mir das erzählen habe lassen, war das genau umgekehrt. Die haben auch gesagt, wir wollen das mal kennenlernen, was wir davon haben, wenn wir so einen Investor haben, was das für Vorteile bringt und für Nachteile hat. Und natürlich brauchte Hertha Geld. Aber das war eigentlich das, im Prinzip war das für die KKR, wie in die Schule gehen. Die haben dann geguckt, wie diese Branche tickt. Die haben Beziehungen geknüpft über Hertha. Die haben versucht zu gucken, wie können sie ihr Netzwerk, was sie aus anderen Branchen haben, im Fußball nutzen. Also ein Beispiel, das habe ich mir mal erzählen lassen, ist, das zeigt nämlich auch, was so ein Investor grundsätzlich für Vorteile mitbringen kann. Also erst mal musste Hertha natürlich ganz anders Finanzen aufarbeiten, also Berichtswesen heißt das, auf Betriebswirtschaftsdeutsch. Und da haben die unheimlich viel von KKR gelernt, wie man überhaupt diese Finanzströme abbildet in so einem Klub. Weil vorher in der Bundesliga war das bis vor 15, 20 Jahren noch alles sehr hemmsärmlich. So. Und das zweite Beispiel war, in der Zeit, als KKR Investor war, hatte Hertha eine verletzten Misere, wie jeder Klub das irgendwann mal hat. Lauter Leute verletzten Leistungsträger. Und die wussten nicht, was haben wir denn falsch gemacht? Also, man fragt sich ja der Klub immer, haben wir die falsch trainiert oder was auch immer. Und da hat KKR gesagt, ja, Problem sehen wir ein. Wir könnten euch da mit jemanden zusammenbringen, wo wir investiert sind in den USA. Die haben da gibt es eine Kette von so Hightech oder Hochleistungskliniken für Sportler. Da ist KKR beteiligt. So. Ja, und dann machen die drei Anrufe und zack. Eine Woche später waren fünf Top-Mediziner von dieser Kette in Berlin und haben gesagt, wir reden mal. Wir gucken uns das mal alles hier an und so. Und vielleicht könnt ihr was von uns lernen. Ob es dann wirklich Effekte hatte, kann ich nicht sagen. Aber es war auf jeden Fall verhärter, hochgradig interessant, weil das Netzwerk, was KKR mitgebracht hat, für die auch in anderen Bereichen Mehrwert gebracht hat, unabhängig von der Wertentwicklung. Das heißt, auf einer kleineren Ebene. Und deswegen bin ich ja auch seit jeher der Meinung, dass Investoren nicht unbedingt Teufelszeug sein müssen, wenn sie richtig gemanagt werden. Weil die musst du genauso managen wie dein Kader und irgendwas anderes auch. Dann können die dem, an einem einzelnen Club zumindest, auch in der Liga, echt was bringen. Und dann zum Schluss, es ist aber eben auch immer die Gefahr, gerade bei diesen Private Equity Granate, wenn die Summen größer werden, dass die alle ein bisschen durchdrehen. Und auf halbs reinfallen wie jeder andere Investor auch. Und das ist eben in dem Fall offensichtlich passiert. Und was jetzt noch am Schluss ist, was interessant ist, ist, dass soweit ich weiß, KKR hat zwar auch noch ein paar Investments gemacht im Sport, aber ich glaube, im Fußball sind die kein Riesenplayer geworden. Da kann man sich jetzt die Frage stellen, warum.
Genau, das war zwischen 2014 und 2018, dann hat Hertha die Anteile zurückgekauft. Und dann kam ja Lars Winhohorst und dann kam Triple Seven und so weiter. Und das ist ja dann auch der Zyklus, in den du reinkommst als Verein. In der Regel hast du nicht mehr die Kapitalmittel, um irgendwann wieder alles zu besitzen. Interessanterweise ist KKR eins von zwei größeren Unternehmen, das jetzt dann eben in das Sportgeschäft von CVC investiert hat. Also sprich, unabhängig von den Clubs sind sie doch reingegangen.
Jaja, aber offensichtlich haben sie gemerkt, oder es könnte sein, dass sie gemerkt haben, dieses kleine, auf der kleinen Ebene, ist hochgradig kompliziert und gar nicht so Erfolgsversprechend, obwohl die, glaube ich, einen ganz guten Schnitt gemacht haben damals, weil sie mit den Anteilen, weil der Windhorst doof genug war, die zu kaufen, ist ja so. Und auf der anderen Seite, wenn sie jetzt über jemand anders gehen, dass dann poolen, das Risiko, mit einer anderen Erwartung reingeht, ist es vielleicht ganz gut, ja. Ich wollte vielleicht noch, Jannik, bevor du rein, noch eine Sache sagen.
Ja, ich wollte, also da kann man auch sagen, das ist, ja, sag mal erst.
Ne, noch ein Punkt. Du hast ja einiges gesagt, Max, die haben das jetzt sozusagen in der neuen Gruppe gepoolt, CVC. Das ist natürlich immer, man kann natürlich auf der einen Seite sagen, na, ist der Art von Bad Bank, die die jetzt aufmachen, so wie die Banken mit ihren ganzen Schrottpapieren. Auf der anderen Seite glaube ich aber auch, dass die natürlich gelernt haben, dass der Sport schon eine sehr eigene Branche ist und du sehr gute Leute brauchst, die die Branche auch kennen, um das zu managen. Jetzt mal ganz neutral betrachtet. CVC hat ja angefangen, das haben die Leute gemacht, die halt auch andere Investments gemacht haben. Und dann haben sie sich so ein bisschen Sport-Know-how eingekauft und haben aber dann vielleicht gemerkt, dass das nicht reicht. Und wenn du eine eigene Unit sagen die ja dann oder ein eigenes Unternehmen daraus machst, hast du natürlich die Möglichkeit, ganz anders zu rekrutieren. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das auch ein Teil des Plans ist, dass die sagen, auf die Weise, wenn ich mich wirklich als, wenn ich so eine Sportgruppe hochziehe, die nur Sport macht, mit Geld von wem auch immer, CVC, KKR, etc., dass du dann ganz andere Führungskräfte anziehen kannst, die möglicherweise es besser managen können, als wenn du das, sagen wir mal, so nebenher machst. Man darf ja nicht sehen, CVC bewegt solche Summen. Da war Sport nie ein Riesenthema für die. Ich sage mal so, das machen die so ein bisschen, ja, mit, so nebenher. Ist für den Sport bitter, aber ist halt von den größten Fällen nicht. Es ist halt so.
Ja, interessant. Tatsächlich, das haben sie gemacht. Also sie haben Marc Alera als Geschäftsführer verpflichtet. Der war früher bei einem Mobilfunkbetreiber und aber auch bei TNT Sports und bei BT Sport. Also genau.
Das gilt ja nicht nur für die Spitze. Das gilt ja auch für die drunter. Die brauchst ja auch drunter noch 10, 15, 20 gute Leute. Und die kriegst du so eben eher, als wenn du das so als ferner liefen in deinem Portfolio hast.
Ja, es ist halt interessant, weil gleich darfst du, Jannik, weil uns bei dem DFL-Prozess die ganze Zeit erzählt wurde, die Investoren, die haben so viel Know-how, die werden uns so krass nach vorne bringen.
Das war immer Blödsinn. Okay, ein bisschen was wissen die schon über ein paar andere Sachen, aber über den Sport selber, da können die noch besser werden.
Jannik.
Sie haben zumindest das Geld, um das Top-Personal einzukaufen. Das muss man denen lassen. Sie haben auch bestimmt die richtigen Kontakt- und Adressen, um dort das richtige Personal zu verpflichten. Ich glaube, am Personal wird es jedenfalls nicht scheitern, wenn da ein Private Equity einsteigt. Aber was ich noch ganz kurz sagen wollte, wir müssen uns einmal ganz kurz diesen Deal genauer anschauen. Es klang gerade so ein bisschen durch, fand ich jedenfalls, dass KKR und PIMCOS, da steckt ja auch noch dahinter, über CVC einsteigen und so eine Art Equity kaufen. Also Anteile erwerben an den jeweiligen Ligen und Rechten. Das Ganze ist aber ein Kreditgeschäft eigentlich. Also so eine Art abgesicherter Kredit mit einer höheren Sicherheit. Das sind letztlich Schulden, um das ganz klar zu sagen. Also man muss das einfach auch mal so sehen, dass CVC sich dadurch Zeit kauft und nicht irgendwie Expertise einkauft. Das ist, glaube ich, dann in dem Punkt nochmal wichtig, weil es was ganz anderes ist. Es ist auch dieses Zeichen nochmal, dass das Infrastrukturenvestment, was ich gerade schon gesagt habe, gesehen wird. Also es wird langweiliger, es wird das Wachstum rausgerechnet. Es ist eine ganz andere Psychologie dahinter, wenn man sagt, wir gehen nicht mehr auf Wachstum, sondern wir wollen stabile Cashflows, wir wollen Gewinne, wir wollen unseren Kredit zurückbekommen. Und das spricht einfach wieder nochmal dafür, dass man dieses Wachstum einfach rausrechnet.
Ja, aber das ist natürlich eine wirklich entscheidende Frage, weil damals, als es um den möglichen Einstieg von CVC bei der DFL ging, haben wir auch darüber gesprochen, was ist denn eigentlich die Exit-Strategie. Weil eben normalerweise bei Private-Equity-Firmen der Exit innerhalb von fünf bis acht Jahren meist ein Verkauf ist oder ein Wir gehen an die Börse und damit kommt dann ganz viel Geld rein und dann ist aber der Investor in der Regel auch wieder raus. Ab dann wird quasi abgerechnet und so was machen die halt an ganz vielen Stellen und das überlappt sich und so können die ständig auch selber einen Cashflow für sich selbst generieren. Und da haben wir damals ja noch darüber diskutiert, dass eben eine Beteiligung im Sport auch eben eher infrastrukturell sein könnte. Wenn man jetzt aber das sieht, dass man, dass sie sich hier Zeit verkaufen, ist ja die Frage, wofür sie sich Zeit verkaufen und sie sagen ja schon eigentlich relativ klar, Jannik, wir wollen so innerhalb der nächsten drei Jahre, wollen wir entweder verkaufen, also so wie es ich verstehe, ist natürlich schwierig, weil es Interpretation, die kompletten Rechte, die sie da haben, oder sie wollen damit an die Börse gehen und damit eben Geld reinholen. Klingt schon ein bisschen anders als so ein Infrastrukturinvestment, oder?
Nochmal kurz zu Deutschland davor, dann können wir gerne auf das andere eben eingehen. Deutschland war ja generell nur auf 20 Jahre angelegt, dann wäre dieser Vertrag hier ausgelaufen. Deswegen war das von vornherein wie so eine Art Infrastrukturinvestment angelegt oder wäre angelegt worden, das hätte ja nicht funktioniert. Ich glaube, die Deutsche muss man immer so ein bisschen ausnehmen aus dieser gesamten Debatte, weil das von vornherein so ein bisschen anders gelagert war. Dann, warum wollen sie sich Zeit erkaufen? Ich glaube, sie müssen sich Zeit erkaufen, weil die Investoren, die Alte Investoren, bei CVC Druck gemacht haben und raus wollten. Das ist jetzt auch nicht ungewöhnlich. Davon wurde 2018 aufgelegt. Das ist jetzt auch acht Jahre her. Also es ist längst überfällig, dass man da irgendwie mal eine Auszahlung vornimmt. Und genau dafür wird dieses Geld ja auch genutzt. Also das frische Geld von KKR und Pimpco wird dafür genutzt, um Alteinvestoren auszubezahlen. Und deswegen, dafür brauchen sie letztlich die Zeit. Und ob es danach an die Börse geht oder was danach damit passiert, das ist halt, wie du auch sagst, Spekulation. Das weiß ich nicht. Das wissen, ich weiß nicht, ob Christoph das weiß, aber ich würde sagen, das wahrscheinlichste Szenario ist nicht der Börsengang, sondern die Schließung des Fonds. Aber das ist nur meine Lesart.
Naja, es gibt natürlich mittlerweile auch, glaube ich, mehr potenzielle Käufer für so ein Geschäft. Also wenn du so ein rechte Paket oder so ein Paket an Sportbeteiligungen hast, wenn du anschaust, was für Riesensport es mittlerweile in Amerika gibt, in den USA, wie viele verschiedenen Sportarten, die teilweise drin sind, wie groß die mittlerweile sind. Da würde ich nicht ausschließen, dass die daraus setzen, dass sie vielleicht in ein paar Jahren das ganze Paket an so jemanden weiter erreichen können. Der kann sich das leisten, der dann wieder entscheidet, okay, das und das, das brauche ich nicht, das verkaufe ich dann weiter. Und insgesamt rächen sich das aber für mich, weil ich über die Vorteile, die ich mit meinem Bestandsportfolio dann noch zusammenschmeißen kann, möglicherweise, für die rechnet. Also solche Player hättest du vor zehn Jahren kaum gehabt, die gibt es aber jetzt. Das heißt, du hast mehr Möglichkeiten. Wenn du Zeit gewinnst, hast du möglicherweise, sind deine Optionen breiter. Weil du kannst es vielleicht an so jemanden, an einen strategischen Investor verkaufen. Du kannst es an die Börse bringen. Du kannst es einzeln verkaufen wieder. Also da ist mehr möglich, als das vor zehn Jahren noch der Fall war. Von daher kann ich die schon strategisch verstehen, dass die sagen, wir kaufen uns sogar mit Krediten Geld. Weil das ist im Prinzip nicht auch so wie du. Das ist kein Investment von KKR in den Sport. Und das ist ein Investment, da gibt KKR, gibt ein Kredit von Geld, was die gerade nicht brauchen. Und da wissen die, da kriegen sie ihre Zinsen. Und wahrscheinlich sind die gar nicht schlecht verzinst. Und das wäre egal, das hätten die genauso gut bei der Chemie, im Chemiebereich oder bei Hightech machen können. Also das, das glaube ich, hat mit Sport nichts zu tun. Es ist recht Zufall, ehrlich gesagt, dass das gerade im Sport ist. Also so würde ich sagen, wir haben schon Möglichkeiten.
Vielleicht auch Risikostreuung gegen KI-Bubble und was weiß ich, was da gerade diskutiert wird, wie du sagst, Christoph, es ist eine Streuung, es ist relativ unabhängig vom Markt und von den Marktrisiken. Da ist Sport dann vielleicht ganz interessant.
Und man muss ganz kurz sagen, also Geld, das KKR gerade nicht gebraucht hat. Wir sprechen hier nach allem, was man weiß, von 1,4 Milliarden US-Dollar von KKR und 1,5 Milliarden US-Dollar von Pimko. Also das sind nur mal kurz die Sohne, die da sind.
Kleingeld, Kleingeld.
Ja, für sie schon. Für jeden anderen. Wenn man jetzt aber mal gegenrechnet, was bisher CVC investiert hat und zu was jetzt eben diese Rechte bewertet werden, dann steht da trotzdem noch ein Plus. Also nach allem, was man weiß, sind es 4,7 Milliarden US-Dollar, die CVC reingesteckt hat in die ganzen Liegenrechte und so weiter und so fort. Und jetzt sind wir ja bei einer Bewertung von 7 Milliarden rausgekommen. Klingt ja Jannik eigentlich dann doch so, als ob es ein Erfolgsgeschäft wäre und keine Bad Bank. Oder ist es jetzt auch wieder Marketing?
Ich habe jetzt die Zahlen so schnell nicht in mein Discounted Cashflow Modell eingeben können, aber ich bin mir sicher, wenn man das über die Zeit, über die acht Jahre, seitdem jetzt abdiskontiert, ist das gar nicht mehr so, dass man da irgendwie aus allen Wolken fällt und denkt, wow, das ist ja eine Wahnsinnsrendite. Man muss es halt immer im Vergleich zur Benchmark setzen oder vielleicht mindestens mal im Vergleich zur Einlagezins, der so als sicherer Zins gilt. Denen können Investoren immer als Alternative anführen, sagen, da könnte ich mein Geld auch sicher da anlegen bei der Bank. Und wenn man das dann daneben hält, sieht es wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr so toll aus. Das war mein erster Gedanke. Ich müsste das mal enden.
Ja, aber du kannst auch die Börsenentwicklung nehmen. Das ist ja eher so das Benchmark, was dann ein Private Equity Messer anlegen würde. Du kannst vom Zins ausgehen, das ist das ganz geringe, oder das ganz untere und du kannst sagen, ok, wenigstens ein großer Weltindex, MSCI World oder was auch immer. Und da wette ich mal, also die sind ja in den letzten sieben, acht Jahren glaub ich gestiegen, trotz der ganzen Krisen, die wir hatten. Also da wären die wahrscheinlich mindestens genauso gut gefahren, wenn sie das Geld einfach an der Börse investiert hätten. Und das wiederum ist eigentlich für die Private Equities nicht die Erwartung, die sie natürlich haben, weil die gehen ja hin und sagen, ihr fahrt viel besser, wenn ihr uns das Geld gebt, das fährt an der Börse an, das kann ja jeder. Wir machen es viel besser und das haben sie eben nicht geschafft. Das ist ein Ding, von dem wir schon angesprochen haben. Falsches Timing und sicherlich auch ein Managementproblem.
Genau, man muss halt auch noch sehen, dass die extrem hohe Kosten haben. Also ich glaube diese Rendite, die du gerade angeführt hast, Max, war noch ohne Kosten. Ich würde mich jedenfalls wundern, wenn die da eingerechnet sind. Und wenn man dann noch die Kosten auf den Carry hat, dann wird es nochmal düsterer.
Aber der Druck erhöht sich jetzt durch das Fremdkapital. Es ist nicht genau Fremdkapital, es ist Preferred Equity, aber sie haben sich letztlich Geld von außen geliehen. Dieser Druck erhöht sich ja. Das heißt, Zinszahlungen oder eben dann Anteilsverkauf, wie es dann bei Preferred Equity wäre, wenn ich es jetzt richtig gecheckt habe. Das erhöht ja jetzt den Druck auf CVC, eben tatsächlich mit diesen Sportbeteiligungen etwas zu tun. Also entweder die ganze Sparte zu schließen, den Fonds zu schließen oder es vielleicht auch nochmal zu zerschlagen. Also ich finde es schon interessant, dass für den bisherigen Gewinn der Sportsparte fast allein La Liga verantwortlich ist mit 300 Millionen Euro und alles andere eigentlich im Grunde so fällt. Da könnte man sich ja vielleicht auch vorstellen, dass man die eine Perle rausnimmt und irgendwie nochmal weiter behält. Aber was glaubt ihr denn? Ich weiß, dass das jetzt sehr spekulativ ist. Aber was glaubt ihr denn bedeutet, dass für die Ligen bei den CVC drinsteckt? Also nehmen wir mal Ligue 1 als Negativbeispiel im Fußball. Da läuft es nämlich gar nicht und La Liga als Positivbeispiel. Jannik, was würdest du vermuten?
Also ich würde zum einen erst mal sagen, dass Finanzierungsgeschäfte einfach das Kerngeschäft sind auch von von solchen Private Equities. Also die würden auch sonst mit mit mit Banken oder mit anderen Private Equities oder wem auch immer. Da würden sie auch Geld und Kredite aufnehmen. Das ist ja die klassische Leverage. Buyout nennt sich das ja zum Beispiel, was man sonst erkennt von Private Equity. Also man kauft eine Firma, pumpt da Schulden rein, verbessert sie oder macht sie effizienter und bringt sie an die Börse und die neuen Investoren bekommen dann die ganzen alten Schulden aufgewürdet. Das sieht man einmal bei Douglas zum Beispiel in der Börse gesehen. Oder da gibt es genug Beispiele. Und ich glaube, insofern ist das jetzt nicht unbedingt was Neues. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass das irgendwie den Druck so massiv erhöht. Auch La Liga oder wem auch immer. Aber klar, also der Wind bläst den jetzt etwas stärker ins Gesicht. Also CVC und man kann davon schon ausgehen, dass sie jetzt noch mal stärker versuchen werden, Synergien zu heben oder wie das dann so schön heißt. Also irgendwie versuchen, noch mal stärker Kooperation zwischen den Clubs zu schaffen. Und das wird sich dann in der Liga genauso auch fortsetzen. Ich glaube halt nur nicht, dass das so fundamental etwas verändern wird.
Aber was heißt denn das für die Liga? Also die Liga hat ja berühmterweise ihren Einstieg auf Lebenszeit verkauft. Also die hatten nicht so ein 20 Jahre Deal, wie es die DFL geplant hat. Unglaublich, wie das zustande kam. Wer weiß, ob wir dazu irgendwie in zehn Jahren mal irgendwann ein gut recherchiertes, investigatives Stück bekommen. Dann ist aber bei Liga, haben Abozahlen nicht gepasst, Sender sind abgesprungen. Ich verkürze jetzt extrem. Letztlich ist die Situation aber jetzt gerade so, dass die Liga das macht, was viele andere auch für sich geplant hat, nämlich sie versucht direkt zu den Fans ihre Rechte zu verkaufen. Sie haben den League-Plus-Kanal gestartet und der sieht eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht aus von den Zahlen her. Also du machst damit natürlich noch nicht die Gewinne, die du mit dem extern gemacht hattest. Aber das ist eigentlich ganz in Ordnung. Da haben wir jetzt aber die jüngste Entwicklung gehabt, dass der Chef von League-Plus, Nicolas de Tamanon, der ist zurückgetreten, hat auf mutmaßlich 500.000 Euro Bonus verzichtet, weil sie wollten sich WM-Spiele kaufen und wurden überboten von Baying Sports. Und wer sitzt bei Baying Sports als Chef? Nasser Al-Kelaifi. Wer sitzt bei PSG als Chef? Nasser Al-Kelaifi. Also mit dem einen Hut, den er aufhat, müsste er eigentlich dafür sein, dass League-Plus wächst. Und mit dem anderen Hut hat er ihn aber komischerweise diese Rechte weggekauft. Und das hat ihn so geärgert, dass der zurückgetreten ist. Ich denke, da ist auch noch mehr passiert wahrscheinlich im Hintergrund. Und die jetzt ohne Chef auf einmal dastehen, von jetzt auf gleich. Also das zeigt ja, wie absurd die Lage ist. Und wie will man denn in diesem Bereich Geld verdienen?
Also zur Personaldebatte, ja, das spricht einfach für sich. Es ist einfach absurd natürlich. Und da gibt es auch gar nicht viel dahin zuzufügen. Was ich noch ganz kurz sagen möchte zu dieser Plattform, dass ich glaube, dass die nicht wirklich im Interesse von CVC sein kann. Und zwar weil bei diesem, wenn man das quasi von einem Broadcaster, also The Zone, wo es ja vorher lag, auf die Liga, das Risiko quasi von Broadcaster auf die Liga überträgt, dann überträgt man ja das Risiko vom Broadcaster auf CVC wiederum. Und dieses Risiko, dass man mehr Risiko bekommt, kann nicht im Interesse von CVC sein, weil man dann von seiner angestrebten Rendite ein bisschen runter muss, weil das Risiko erhöht ist. Also ich glaube, das spült definitiv nicht CVC in die Karten. Aber ich wünsche mir, was Christoph auch noch dazu sagen kann.
Die Eingangs, hast du ja gefragt, haben die jetzt eine andere Situation in Frankreich? Ich glaube, so wie die Jannik, dass sie eigentlich nicht so viel anders ist, weil natürlich der Druck ist sowieso immer extrem, wenn du mit solchen Investoren arbeitest. Und der innere Druck für die Liga sich zu entwickeln, ist auch sehr hoch, also unabhängig von den Investoren. Und gerade für die französische Liga ist sehr, sehr hoch, weil die natürlich ein riesen Problem haben. Die sind eigentlich eine relativ operetten Liga, weil viel zu viele Klubs nicht wettbewerbsfähig sind, noch viel stärker als bei uns. Ich habe lange in Frankreich gelebt, also ich kenne jetzt die Liga nicht so gut, aber ich kenne Frankreich ganz gut und die Fußballkultur so ein ganz kleines bisschen. Und ich habe in Bordeaux lange gelebt und die sind ja völlig abgestürzt. Und dann hast du noch einen Player wie PSG, der so massiv, riesig, viel größer ist als alles andere. Das stellt ja alles im Schatten, was wir in Deutschland kennen, mit Bayern, die Unterschiede da. Und was es ja auch noch erläutert, gerade mit den personalen, personellen Verpflichtungen, die du auch noch hast, die du da mitgewinnt und die macht Ungleichgewicht. Das sind die viel größeren Probleme, glaube ich, die die haben. Und deswegen ist das, ich habe das von vornherein nicht verstanden, dass CVC in so eine Liga geht, weil die einfach von vornherein sehr unattraktiv aussah. Deswegen, glaube ich, hat sich da nicht viel verändert. Ich wollte aber noch einen Punkt sagen, wo manch mal so Missgriffe auch eine interessante Folgen haben können. Weil die Tatsache, dass die Liga jetzt selbst vermarktet, das wird schwierig für die. Und ich sehe es auch für Jannik. Das ist natürlich ein enormes Risiko. Auf der anderen Seite guckt ihr an, was sonst so passiert. Also Deutschland will ja jetzt internationalen Rechte selbst vermarkten, weil die selber merken, eine Plattform hochziehen. Was sie auch schon mit CVC machen wollen, jetzt machen sie es ja selber. Da läuft ja schon länger dieser Prozess, dass hier Ausschreibung läuft. Es war chaotisch bei der DFL wie oft, aber die versuchen es auch. Das heißt, du hast jetzt aber einen Fall in Frankreich, wo dich die Branche das angucken kann, wie die das machen, wie das funktioniert. Weil die lernen da enorm viel. Es mag sein, dass Frankreich das nicht hinkriegt und Fehler macht und die irgendwann merken, ach, gehen wir doch, wir kommen bei so klein mit Hut zurück zu der Zone oder wie auch immer. Alles nicht auszuschließen. Aber das ist eine unglaublich interessante Manöver für alle liegen, weil die ja auch alle überlegen jetzt, aha, wir sehen, hatte ich eingangs schon gesagt, Broadcasting Revenue, also die Medienrechte, das wächst nicht mehr, so wächst es überhaupt nicht mehr, wird schwieriger. Die Hoffnung, dass Player wie Amazon, Apple TV und so weiter den Markt noch mal verändern, weil die sich draufstürzen, wie die kloppen, ist auch nicht wirklich so passiert. Das hatte man zwischendurch auch an der Bundesliga mal gehofft. Die kommen jetzt und dann steigen die Preise wieder an. Hat aber nicht funktioniert bisher. Jetzt müssen die alle einen Plan B haben. Der Plan B ist Selbstvermarktung. Klar, wie in Spanien kennt man das ja, da wollen die ja eh die beiden großen Klubs schon ewig am liebsten machen. Die finden das eh scheiße mit der Gesamtvermarktung, weil die eben auch wiederum so global sind, wie die anderen alle nur träumen können, wie sie sein würden. Aber das ist super interessant für die Branche, dass sie das jetzt ausprobieren. Und ich wette, dass in Frankfurt die DFL da, wenn die können, würde die da einen reinsetzen, der sich das jeden Tag anguckt, wie die das machen, weil das so interessant ist, wie das funktioniert. Und das ist dann, wenn du so willst, eine Folge, die echt für die ganze Branche sehr spannend ist, weil du jetzt diese Notwendigkeit bekommen hast, in Frankreich durch dieses Chaos mal sowas selber zu versuchen.
Diese Plattform war ja sogar Plan der ursprünglichen DFL-Investorengeschichte. Genau.
Und genau deswegen, um unabhängiger zu werden bei den Ausschreibungen von den Großen, dass du vielleicht sogar irgendwann sagen kannst, ich habe eine Plattform, die läuft und wenn du, The Zone, Sky, wer auch immer, jetzt nicht den Preis bezahlst, dann geben wir dir halt das Paket nicht, machen wir den selber. Und das ist nicht auszuschließen, dass das immer wichtiger wird. Strategisch als Liga musst du eigentlich auch darauf vorbereitet sein. Und dann musst du natürlich auch das so gut machen, sofort, dass du das so gut vermarktet kriegst. Das ist echt schwierig, dass du dann deine Erlösströme einigermaßen zumindest stabil halten kannst. Und das ist dann das Risiko dabei. Genau wie Jannik sagt, du musst das hochfahren von Null. Die haben keine Abonnentendaten erst mal, die haben gar nichts. Und das ist eben in diesem Streamingbereich extrem wichtig. Die kriegen es ja auch nicht von Sky. Das heißt, es wird dauern. Und deswegen gucken die da alle drauf. Und das ist schon sehr interessant.
Ich kann euch sogar sagen, wo noch alle hingucken. Also ich weiß auch, dass die die DFL sehr genau auf die Ligue 1 blickt. Und ab jetzt werden auch alle nach Singapur gucken. Denn die Premier League hat das jetzt erst jüngst bekannt gegeben, dass man in Singapur Premier League Plus startet, mit einer eigenen Streaming-Plattform. Erstmal noch parallel zu den Rechten, die man dort verkauft hat. Die Premier League macht ja auch mehr Geld mit den internationalen Rechten als mit den heimischen Rechten seit der letzten Rechtevergabe. Aber ja, das ist auf jeden Fall der Weg, der da gegangen wird. Trotzdem stelle ich mir aber halt die Frage, Jannik...
Das macht die Bundesliga ja auch. Die DFL macht es ja auch schon. Also du kannst ja schon in einzelnen Märkten, kannst ja schon einst in Spiele Brasilien, glaube ich, so markt. Da gibt es ja drei, vier Märkte.
Das macht es aber die Bundesliga. Ja, natürlich.
Ja, gut. Ja, aber warum man sich bei beide Markts sich geändert hat und weil sie gesagt haben, okay, dann muss ich eben selber die Erfahrung machen. Und das haben die ja schon angefangen mit auszuräumen, mit OneFootball und so. Also da passiert ja auch schon was. Aber klar, hochspannend.
Aber jetzt, wir kamen ja quasi von der Frage, was das für die Ligen heißt. Und wir haben jetzt bei der Ligue 1 ja so ein durchwachsenes Bild. Die geht halt jetzt so ihren eigenen Weg. Und letztlich hat er, und das will ich halt schon noch mal kurz festhalten, was uns ja allen erzählt wurde, als es darum ging, ein möglicher Investor steigt ein, war ja blühende Landschaften. Der Investor kommt mit all seinem Know-how und mit all seinem Geld. Und dann wird es jeder Liga besser gehen. Und bei der Ligue 1 müssen wir sagen, da kommen natürlich externe Faktoren rein. Aber sorry, die sind halt nicht weg, wenn ein Investor kommt. Der Ligue 1 geht es jetzt aktuell nicht besser. Da sind ganz, ganz viele Clubs so finanziell geschwächt gewesen, dass da jetzt die Investoren richtig durchgerutscht sind und sich da den ein oder anderen gekauft haben. Werden wir gleich noch drüber sprechen. Mit La Liga haben wir ja aber auch noch ein Positivbeispiel. Ich habe vorhin leider eine falsche Zahl genannt. Es sind nicht 300 Millionen Euro, die La Liga an Gewinn abwirft, sondern 150 Millionen Euro pro Jahr an CVC aktuell. Also in Private Equity Größen ist es quasi irgendwie eine Nachkommastelle. Aber immerhin ist es ein Gewinn. Jannik, was denkst du, wie kann es denn da weitergehen? Weil auch La Liga hat ja ein zeitlich begrenzten Vertrag mit CVC, ist noch ein bisschen anders strukturiert und ist auch ein bisschen komplizierter durch die Klagen, die es dann noch gab, einiger großer Clubs. Müssen wir jetzt glaube ich nicht ins Detail gehen. Aber ist ja die Frage, wird das vielleicht so ein Fall sein, wo man dann so ein Fallbeispiel sein im nächsten CVC-Bericht irgendwie in zehn Jahren, wo sie sagen, guck mal, da sind wir drin geblieben und jetzt ist das XY wert?
Also wenn wir jetzt speziell von Spanien reden oder La Liga reden, ich glaube man muss speziell diesen einzelnen Markt für sich betrachten. Also Frankreich haben wir jetzt die ganzen Probleme verkürzt, jedenfalls auch dargestellt. Frankreich ist glaube ich ein ganz eigener Problemfall nochmal. Spanien hat Vorteile, genau wie England, vor allen Dingen kulturell und sprachlich. Das spanische Fußball wird auch in Südamerika viel stärker geschaut, in Mexiko stärker geschaut. Und sie haben mit den drei Top-Teams, mit Barcelona, mit Real, mit Atletico drei Weltmarken da drin. In Frankreich gibt es mit Paris Saint-Germain so ein künstliches Konstrukt, dass da künstlich hochgepusht wird. Und diese globalen Marken sind von Spanien viel stärker. Deswegen glaube ich auch, dass Spanien dort eher noch mal die Chance hat, auch das Abzuwerfen an zu gewinnen. Das zeigt sich nämlich immer wieder, auch wenn wir vielleicht noch über Multi-Club-Ownership sprechen später. Das sind die besten Multi-Club-Ownership, sind solche mit den großen Marken. Also die großen Marken funktionieren und insofern glaube ich halt auch, dass große Ligen mit großen Marken, wie in Spanien oder wie in England vor allen Dingen, noch mal stärker von so Private Equity profitieren könnten, als Frankreich mit, wie du auch gesagt hast, mit den ganzen Personellenverflechtungen, mit den ganzen Problemen mit den Medienrechten, mit MediaPro und Dizone und was es da alles für Probleme gab. Ich würde deswegen sagen, dass Spanien noch mal eine größere Chance hat.
Aber dann lass doch mal zu diesem zweiten Themenkomplex kommen, weil das ist ja wirklich auffällig. Es gibt quasi zwei Arten, in denen Investoren im Sport investiert sind. Und das eine ist eben jetzt so diese Nummer wie CVC, wie Ares, wie Apollo. Das sind jetzt einfach nur weitere Firmen, die ich da genannt habe, die sich komplette Liegenrechte, TV-Rechte und so weiter kaufen, also quasi in oben reingehen. Und dann gibt es aber ja das berühmte Multiclub-Ownership. Das heißt, ein Investor beteiligt sich an einem Verein und an einem weiteren Verein und an noch einem Verein, egal ob in der Mehrheits- oder einer Minderheitsbeteiligung. Sie stecken irgendwann überall drin. Und das ist ja der große Trend. Wir haben laut einer UEFA-Studie 2015 hatten wir 60 Vereine in Multiclub-Ownership-Strukturen. 20, 25, 10 Jahre später waren es 345 Vereine in Multiclub-Ownership-Strukturen. Es ist hier in manchen Ligen, vor allem in England, egal ob erste, zweite oder dritte Liga, es ist eigentlich fast unmöglich, einen Verein zu finden, der nicht irgendwie in einem solchen Multiclub-Ownership-Konstrukt drin hängt. Also nur um die Zahlen mal kurz zu nennen. In England sind es in den ersten drei Ligen 42 Teams, die eben in solchen MCOs mit drin hängen. Zum Vergleich, in Deutschland sind es 16. Also es gibt einen deutlichen Unterschied. Aber auch in Deutschland haben wir da vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr, als man denkt. Jetzt ist aber auch hier die Sache, Christoph, wenn man sich die Zahlen anguckt. Also zum Beispiel die City Football Group, die ja so mit eins der bekanntesten MCOs war in der Vergangenheit. Die haben unheimlich viel Geld bewegt. Also inzwischen fast eine Milliarde US-Dollar. Aber die haben seit ihrer Gründung in 13 Jahren es nicht geschafft, Gewinn zu machen. Sie haben über verschiedene Runden, 2015, 2019, 2021, haben sie immer wieder neues Geld, zum Teil auch neue Investoren mit reinholen müssen. Also zum Beispiel ist ein chinesisches Konsortium sehr früh schon eingestiegen. Die Silver Lake Group ist mit eingestiegen und am Schluss haben sie sich Kredite genommen. Was sagt denn das über diese zweite Art des Investments aus? Jetzt haben wir ja schon wieder hier Investoren, die sich dann irgendwie dann doch Kredite reinholen müssen, weil sie keinen Gewinn machen.
Ich glaube, jetzt muss man nochmal kurz grundsätzlich blicken auf die Art von, besondere Art von Unternehmen, die Fußballklubs sind. Fußballklubs sind ja keine normalen Unternehmen. Normales Unternehmen bedeutet für mich, ich betreibe ein Geschäft und ich will einen Gewinn machen. Das gilt ja für die Fußballklubs in der Regel nicht. Du willst ja, in deinem Gewinn ist sportlicher Natur. Du willst sportlich performen. Das bildet sich ja auch ab in den finanziellen Regeln, die sich mittlerweile entwickelt haben. Bei der UEFA zum Beispiel. Eigentlich sollen die Klubs einigermaßen pro Saison auf Null rauskommen. Break-even schaffen, aber du sollst keine Verluste machen. Wegen der Wettbewerbsverzerrung, aber auch weil es wirtschaftlich einfach irgendwann nicht mehr tragbar ist. Und das heißt, Multi-Club-Ownership muss man meines Erachtens, würde ich nicht bewerten, an der Frage, ob die Gewinn machen. Also wird betriebswirtschaftlich Gewinn machen. Jetzt ist natürlich auch noch City ein besonderer Fall, weil du hast eben so einen riesigen Hauptinvestor, der dem Geld keine Rolle spielt, der dahinter steckt. Aber grundsätzlich ist natürlich der Ansatz, der dahinter steckt, einer, den die ein Stück weit aus der Nicht-Sportwirtschaft importiert haben, weil natürlich auch als Konzern in irgendeiner anderen Branche sagst, naja, ist es sinnvoll für mich, also Dependance in anderen Ländern zu anderen Märkten zu haben, die Märkte dort kennenzulernen, Synergien zu heben, Personal auszutauschen, gemeinsam einzukaufen und solche banalen Sachen zu tun. Und damit spare ich Geld, also als Nationalteam will ich Gewinn machen, das hilft mir. So, und das ist die Übertragung aus dieser Logik in den Fußball. Das Problem dabei ist eben, dass du natürlich dieses Problem mit dem Wettbewerb bekommst, weil du das haben wir ja bei Leipzig und Salzburg schon erlebt, ganz konkret, dass die da auf einmal die Farben lieben, die laufen beide in den selben Wettbewerb rein, das geht natürlich nicht. Das haben wir in der Formel 1 ja übrigens auch mit der Stallorder, also da gibt es das ja auch, ein Stück weit, wenn dann in der Saison der Stall sagt, okay, das Team sagt, naja, es ist besser, wenn der andere gewinnt und dann lässt er den anderen überholen. Ja, also das gibt es auch in anderen Sportarten, ein Stück weit, aber so, das ist der Unterschied. Und grundsätzlich ist da eine enorme Logik da drin, dass du so Ökosysteme schaffst. Es ist nur ganz offensichtlich im Fußball sehr viel komplizierter, das erfolgreich zu machen als für einen Weltkonzern wie BASF oder irgendwer, der halt überall in allen Märkten ist und so. Woran das liegt, können wir gerne diskutieren, aber jüngst noch, weil es gerade so schön passt, unsere Kollegen von 11Freunde haben ja gerade die Titelgeschichte über RB Leipzig gemacht, wo ja die These ist und eigentlich auch ganz gut erklärt. Natürlich Momentaufnahme, weil die sportlich alle nicht erfolgreich sind, aber wo die halt sagen, naja, die haben das zu den bestimmten, also gerade im deutschsprachigen Raum extrem ausgewalzt. Dieses Beispiel Großinvestor, Multiclub und dann Ökosystem schaffen und sich sozusagen unterstützen, dass alle sich irgendwann nach oben entwickeln, funktioniert nicht mehr, ist die These der Kollegen. Und ich würde es so sehen, ich fand Leipzig teilweise schon echt interessant, was die gemacht haben und unabhängig von der Ausstrahlung, die die vielleicht nicht hatten, aber managementtechnisch schon sehr interessant. Das hängt aber auch immer extrem von den Leuten ab, die das machen. Und in Leipzig ist auch die These des Kollegen, sind halt viele Leute nicht mehr da, die das ursprünglich vorangetrieben haben, die vieles am Anfang richtig gemacht haben, wahrscheinlich, aus der Sicht des Systems zumindest. Und wenn du die nicht mehr hast, die das nicht mehr vorleben und Herr Klopp macht es offensichtlich auch nicht oder er ist nicht in der Lage, das umzusetzen, was er da eigentlich umsetzen sollte für Herrn Minzlaw, dann hat auch so ein Modell keine Vorteile mehr oder sogar vielleicht eher Nachteile. Aber grundsätzlich, es ist die Übertragung eines wirtschaftlichen Prinzips in den Fußball, den nicht in jedem Aspekt eingepreist hat, dass der Fußball anders funktioniert. Da die Übertragung, das ist wirklich per Frisbusser, hat noch nicht funktioniert. Das kann man vielleicht hinkriegen, weiß ich nicht. Noch ist es, glaube ich, nicht gelungen. Jannik?
Ja, genau. Also ich ganz kurz noch an Leipzig oder an den Red Bull-Konzernen da irgendwie anknüpfend. Ich glaube, das hat in der Vergangenheit auch eben ganz gut funktioniert, weil es ja diesen Konsens oder gewissermaßen eine Art Konsens gab, dass man nicht komplett an die Spitze strebt. Also das beste Club in diesem System ist ja Leipzig. Und Leipzig hat sich immer irgendwie so ein bisschen darauf verständigt, dass man sagt, wenn wir die besten Spieler können, wir verkaufen. Das ist jetzt zum Beispiel bei City nochmal eine ganz andere Nummer. Also da City ist eine Endstation im Profi-Fußball. Und wenn man das als Unternehmerische in Sicht sieht, macht dieses System halt deutlich mehr Sinn nochmal als die City Group, wenn man quasi eine Endstation im eigenen System hat. Und das war vielleicht noch ein Grund, warum das Malte Club ownership bei Red Bull ganz gut funktioniert hat im Vergleich zu anderen Modellen, wo du ja gerade auch schon gesagt hast, Max, dass wenig Gewinn abgeworfen wird. Dann würde ich auch noch einmal ergänzen vielleicht zu Christoph. Ich sehe das ganz genauso, dass diese Synergien vielleicht ein bisschen sich auch herbeigezaubert wurden. Und man de facto an so ein paar Hürden gerade kommt. Zum einen gibt es ja auch Studien darüber, dass viele Clubs einfach deutlich teurer geworden sind als noch vor fünf oder zehn Jahren. Klar, kommen doch Inflationen so ein bisschen dazu. Aber das ist einfach deutlich teurer als das, was sich die Investoren damals auch vorgestellt haben, bevor sie eingestiegen sind. Dann kommt das, was Christoph gerade gesagt hat, hinzu mit der Regulierung. Es gibt ja diese Grundregel, dass die UEFA nicht erlaubt, dass zwei Clubs mit demselben Eigentümer im selben Wettbewerb spielen dürfen. Es gab schon Leipzig und ich glaube, es gab es ja noch mehr bei Brighton und St. Judeuasse und sowas.
Ja und Crystal Palace und Lyon war jetzt der prominenteste Fall. Deswegen mussten Crystal Palace in die Conference League.
Genau. Aber was ich noch sagen wollte, vielleicht der wichtigste Punkt, ist diese Art von Kultur, wo man keine Synergien schaffen kann. Das kennt ja jeder aus einer Firma, die mal übernommen wurde. Schönen Gruß auch an die Freunde, die glaube ich damals sehr damit gehadert haben, dass RTL die übernehmen wollte oder auch kurzzeitig übernommen hat. Und ich weiß nicht, ob ich das erzählen darf, aber ich weiß, wir gehören ja auch zu dieser Gruppe. Da gab es gewisse Diskussionen darum, ob man wirklich die E-Mail-Adresse at rtl.de haben will. Das ist jetzt klar ein bisschen nischig, aber das zeigt einfach nur, dass, ich glaube, beschätzt wird, wie sehr Kulturen claschen können. Also wenn man jetzt einen Club in Spanien übernimmt und dann im nächsten Moment einen da in Australien kauft, okay, da sind vielleicht kein gutes Beispiel, also in China oder Südamerika noch dazu kauft, das sind unterschiedliche Märkte. Und ich glaube, da wird so ein bisschen zu viel Euphorie da irgendwie oder zu viel Phantasie reingesteckt für das, was am Ende dabei rauskommen soll. Und das zeigt sich, glaube ich, gerade auch.
Und das, finde ich, ist nämlich der entscheidende Punkt. Was soll eigentlich dabei herauskommen? Also als Roman Abramovic sich Chelsea gekauft hat, oder als Abu Dhabi und Qatar sich PSG und Manchester City einverleibt haben, oder als Red Bull seinen Multiclub-Ownership aufgezogen hat, dann haben die das ja nicht getan, um da wieder Geld rauszuziehen, sondern die wollten damit einen anderen Effekt erziehen. Sie wollten Sportswashing betreiben, sie wollten Marketing für ihr Produkt machen, vielleicht wollten sie auch einfach nur zeigen, wie cool sie sind. Aber jetzt sind ja andere Investoren drin. Jetzt hängen ja eben die Eagle Football Holding steckt mit drin und denen gehört nämlich unter anderem Crystal Palace, Portofogo und Lyon. Wir haben so einen lustigen Fall, oder was heißt lustig? In Anführungszeichen lustig, Ares, das ist einer, den ich vorhin auch genannt habe. Die gehen auch eben auch Private Equity. Die sind bei Atletico, Chelsea und Lyon drin, jeweils als Minderheitsbeteiliger und entscheidet dann aber auch gleichzeitig, weil sie auch mit drin hängen in der Ligue 1 und La Liga und Premier League, über den Einstieg von Ares. Also zwar nur mit einer Stimme von einem Verein, aber das ist natürlich ein Szenario, das relativ absurd ist. Gleichzeitig frage ich mich aber, was wollen denn die da eigentlich rausziehen, außer den Exit? Denn wir wissen ja, alles Geld, was du verdienst, selbst wenn jetzt Rhabar Leipzig wird Deutscher Meister, dann kriegen sie eine Meisterpräne, die ist gar nicht so riesig und sie verkaufen ein paar mehr Trikots, damit machen sie gar nicht so viel Geld. Aber es ist ja nicht so, dass dieses Geld dann rausgezogen wird aus dem Verein und irgendwie an Investor verteilt, sondern das wird halt, ja das geht halt in Verträge und so weiter. Also Fußball ist ja letztlich ein Verlustgeschäft. Die versuchen quasi alle so ganz hart am Wind zu segeln, dass sie eben nicht umkippen. Und deswegen frage ich mich Christoph, warum gehen da überhaupt solche Investoren rein? Das ergibt doch gar keinen Sinn, wenn du nicht ein anderes Ziel als eben Geld verdienen damit verfolgst.
Na ja, die wollen über den Exit Geld verdienen irgendwann. Auch mit den Multiclubs, das ist dasselbe Prinzip. Die wissen schon, so naiv sind die nicht, dass die aus dem Fußball-Tagesgeschäft keine großen Renditen erzielen können. Das ist glaube ich klar. Das heißt, wenn du das jetzt ganz, sagen wir mal, sarkastisch ausdrückend sagst, die wollen dann am Ende einen Dümmeren finden, der ihnen abkauft. Das ist wie Bitcoin. Vor dem Hintergrund der Magnetwirkung, die der Fußball speziell hat auf Investoren aus den verschiedensten Gründen, ist das ja auch eine Wette, die man durchaus eingehen kann. Dass dann irgendwann jemand kommt und sagt, ich will das auch. Einen Punkt haben wir jetzt noch nicht besprochen. Das ist die Logik dahinter. Und natürlich stückweit auch der Glaube daran, dass man, wenn man mehrere Clubs hat, dass man da Synergien heben kann. Das ist genau das, was Jannik aus sich sieht, ist auch so. Das klappt halt eher begrenzt. Ich will aber noch einen Punkt sagen, der sicherlich auch die dazu verleitet, das zu tun. Wir haben, ich hätte eben schon mal kurz angesprochen, dass so jemand wie CVC natürlich auch händeringend nach Leuten sucht, nach Managern, Führungskräften, die sowas managen können für die. Also einmal für die Investoren, aber das gilt ja auch für die Clubs. Und dass du Leute findest, die solche Clubs überhaupt gut managen können. Ich fand in diesem UEFA-Report, den ich eingangs erwähnt hatte, wo die UEFA ihre Zahlen für das ganze Jahr zusammenstellt und zu den großen Trends rausarbeitet, eine Sache war auch interessant. Und zwar, dass in den letzten, ich glaube, drei oder vier Jahren, die Kosten der Clubs für Führungskräfte um 40 Prozent gestiegen sind, während die Gehälter der Spieler sich eigentlich fast nicht verändert haben. Das heißt, die Diskussionen, dass die Spieler immer teurer werden, sind klar, unglaublich teuer und viel zu teuer. Das hat sich mittlerweile ziemlich aufgehört. Aber die Führungskräfte werden immer teurer. Woran liegt das? Meiner Meinung nach, das liegt daran, weil du immer bessere Leute brauchst, die solche komplexen Unternehmen, Markenunternehmen, mit diesem extrem anspruchsvollen Fußballumfeld auch erfolgreich managen können. Wenn du jetzt einen Club hast und du hast da ein paar Leute, denen du zutraust, die können das, die sind zwar total teuer, die kosten mittlerweile dann fast so viel wie die nicht ganz so guten Spieler. Ja, ein Schweinegeld kannst du da verdienen im Fußball, aber die können das eben auch. Dann zu sagen, ich vertraue denen noch zwei, drei andere Clubs an, weil das können die da bestimmt nebenher genauso machen, ist nicht unbedingt jetzt, also sag mal so, das kann ich schon nachvollziehen, wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren in den meisten Fällen, aber du hast einfach auch, genau wie du immer weniger Top-Spieler hast, wenn du in die Pyramide hochgehst, jetzt hast du auch immer weniger Top-Führungskräfte, die sowas managen können und die dann eben auch die Weltentwicklung herbeiführen können, die du dir als Investor erhoffst. Und ich glaube, dass ein Stück weit diese Modelle auch geschuldet sind, weil die glauben, sie kriegen sonst die Leute nicht, weil wenn du dann eine Ausschreibung machst und sagst, du kannst hier bei einem Club X, Y, Z in Frankreich Mittelfeld in der Liga anfangen, Geschäftsführer werden, oder du kannst von einem, naja, sagen wir mal, kleinen Fußball Imperium mit regelmäßigen Dienstreisen nach Brasilien und Japan Chef werden, dann kriegst du eine ganz andere Gehaltsstruktur. Das ist auch, glaube ich, ein bisschen Employer Branding, dass die hoffen, sie kriegen bessere Leute. Das muss nicht funktionieren und es gibt da genauso, wie gesagt, es gibt ja auch nicht so viele Super-Duper-Trainer. Das wird immer weniger nach oben. Und das Gleiche gilt auch für die Manage-Manager, die solche Clubs, solche Strukturen managen können, weil das ist extrem anspruchsvoll. Darf man nicht unterschätzen, wie schwierig das ist. Noch ein Satz, wir hören immer wieder, wir haben ja nun jede Woche mit DAX-Vorständen und mit großen Familienunternehmern zu tun, die Management machen müssen in einer normalen Wirtschaft jeden Tag. Und die gucken eigentlich seit Jahren immer mehr auf die Fußballmanager, nicht weil die Firmen so groß wären. Klar, die werden auch größer, Bayern ist fast eine Milliarde oder was machen die, glaube ich, Umsatz. Nenne ich ganz, aber fast. Ich glaube, Basa ist bei einer Milliarde. Aber die sehen halt die Manager aus der normalen Wirtschaft, wie anspruchsvoll diese Jobs sind. Und gucken mit einer gewissen Bewunderung auf diese Leute im Fußball, weil du einen enormen öffentlichen Druck hast, ganz schwieriges Umfeld hast, ganz viele verschiedene Charaktere managen musst. Allein so einen Chef-Trainer, der da 25 Profis hat, die extrem unterschiedlichsten Bildungsstand haben, nicht die gleiche Sprache sprechen, eigentlich schon auf den nächsten Club gucken, wo sie den nächsten gehen wollen, das zu managen und zum Erfolg zu führen, ist extrem schwierig. Und die lachen eigentlich über die ganzen DAX-Vorstände, die einmal in Quartalzahlen vorlegen müssen und sonst eigentlich nur, naja, wir Geschäft machen müssen. Ich finde das auch echt wichtig.
Die Arbeit dafür hat 40.000 Mitarbeiter und nicht irgendwie so wie Bayern.
Ja gut, aber die kennen sie ja nicht alle. Die Verantwortung, die Verkennungszwecklichkeiten.
Also vielleicht, also ehrlicherweise, ich glaube dir alles, was du sagst, aber das ist ja eine groteske Überschätzung des Fußballs und auch von Einzelpersonen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es so grotesk ist, ich darf es doch nicht vergessen. Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, nur weil Adidas 60.000 Mitarbeiter hat, bei einem mittelgroßen Bundesliga-Klub, du arbeitest ja de facto auch für alle Mitglieder oder Fans. Du hast natürlich eine Stakeholder-Gruppe, die ist noch viel größer als bei Adidas.
Also wenn Adidas jetzt nicht gerade ein neues Trikot vorstellt, ist das ja weitaus weniger politisch als ein Fußballverein, sage ich mal.
Oh, da könnt ihr euch auf das erste Nike-Trikot vom DFB freuen, da habe ich ganz fürchterliche Geschichten. Ich habe nur Geschichten gehört bisher, aber der DFB ist schockiert. Aber gut, das ist jetzt mal ein komplett anderes Thema.
Die werden noch ganz anders schockiert werden von Nike, aber das wird man dann sehen.
Ja, das habe ich auch schon gehört. Aber um das noch kurz zu sagen, ich werde natürlich diesen UEFA-Report verlinken. Ich habe ihn auch gelesen. Deutschland ist tatsächlich auf Platz zwei bei der Steigerung, wie viel mehr Geld eben in diese Nicht-Spieler-Gehälter reinging. Also auf Platz eins ist es die Premier League und dann kommt tatsächlich schon Deutschland. Aber Jannik, du wolltest auch schon etwas sagen.
Nö, also eigentlich nur fast noch ergänzend an Christoph. Also man muss, also zu dem Punkt, dass die keinen Gewinn erzählen, könnte halt auch dieses Thema Wachstum einfach noch mal entzukommen. Also es ist wie bei Wachstumsunternehmen bei, keine Ahnung, bei Magnificent Seven an der Börse, also so Google und wie sie alle heißen. Die machen jetzt zwar viel Gewinn, aber, oder nennen wir das mal jüngere Unternehmen, die müssen nicht unbedingt Gewinn erzielen, solange die Wachstumsgeschichte aufwärts geht. Also du musst ständig eine neue Geschichte erfinden, um den Leuten, wie Christoph sagt, diese Greater Fool Theorie, also du musst das immer in den Next Dimmeren verkaufen können. Und das, ja, solange sich narrativ diese Geschichte aufrechtgehalten wird, solange man vom Wachstum erzählen kann, solange die Leute das jedenfalls abkaufen, solange es Gewinn erstmal, glaube ich, zweitrangig.
Ja, okay, also das ist ja quasi das Bitcoin-Prinzip. Solange es immer noch neue Leute reingeht, die reingehen, dann ist es egal, dass eigentlich alle Bitcoins drei Leuten gehören.
Und jetzt sind wir endgültig auf dem Index bei YouTube.
Ja, ja, und ich freue mich auch auf die E-Mails, aber es ist mir egal, Leute, ich habe recht, werden wir schon in ein paar Jahren dann noch sehen. Aber das, okay, das verstehe ich ja, aber gleichzeitig bewegen wir uns ja jetzt hier nicht in einem abgeschlossenen Zirkel, in dem halt die Sportbewertungen wachsen. Also mir ist es zum Beispiel aufgefallen, bei der Major League Soccer sind logischerweise auch, da sind insgesamt 17 Teams in Multiclub-Ownership-Strukturen drin. Wundert einen ja auch nicht wirklich. Und da ist die Bewertung der Teams extrem hoch und die ist auch extrem gestiegen. Aber man muss dazusagen, diese Bewertung, die wird so ein bisschen aus der Luft gegriffen. Also klar, liegen da ökonomische Zahlen drunter, aber letztlich sind es dann Branchenportale oder irgendwelche Analysten, die da einfach mal so eine Zahl hinschreiben und dann sagen die ja, Inter Miami ist jetzt x-wert und Vancouver Whitecaps ist y-wert und so weiter. Und ob das aber wirklich mal so ist, das liegt eben dann daran, ob man den Greater Fool findet. Aber wir befinden uns ja auch innerhalb einer Weltwirtschaft und wir wissen ja, gerade so Private Equity Geld ist dann schon eines, was sehr fluide ist. Denn es fließt dahin, wo die Rendite noch möglich ist. Und gleichzeitig sehen wir, im Sport sind wenige Investoren jetzt sehr breit investiert. Und du kommst eigentlich auch als kleiner Investor gar nicht mehr rein. Das sagen Analysten, die sich das ganze Feld des Sport-Investments angucken, sagen das selbst inzwischen. Kann das nicht auch heißen, Jannik, wenn einer fällt, dann fallen alle? Also lass zum Beispiel am einen Ende des Spielfelds die KI-Bubble platzen und dann trickelt das rüber und dann ist es aber ganz schnell so, dass im Sport gar nicht mehr hochbewertet wird. Und dann, ja, was passiert denn dann eigentlich?
Ja, also das kann auf jeden Fall passieren. Das hat dann aber, also wenn es so weit kommt, dann hat nicht nur ein Sport ein Problem, also das ist ganz unabhängig. Das ist definitiv ein Thema, was aber immer wieder auch diskutiert wird. Das haben wir aktuell zum Beispiel auch bei der Debatte um Zinsen, um höhere Zinsen, die sich jetzt zum Beispiel jetzt gerade aus dem Iran-Krieg da ergeben könnten, wenn die Ölpreise weiter hoch bleiben, dass die Zinsen dann steigen müssten. Und gerade das würde halt PIV massive Probleme führen, weil das Druck auf die Bewertung macht. Und das würde dann halt auch entsprechend auf die Bewertung im Sport drücken im nächsten Schritt. Das passiert jetzt dann alles nicht von heute auf morgen, aber das sind Entwicklungen, die dann irgendwie real werden. Und dann wird man sich ganz genau fragen. Also es ist immer die Dynamik. Es wird erst mal geguckt, was wirklich werthaltig ist und was nicht werthaltig ist. Und das war zum Beispiel 2022 bei dem letzten Zinszyklus, als der Zins nach oben gegangen ist, war es ja auch so, dass Tech-Werte oder unprofitable Werte als erstes abgestraft werden. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass, wenn das so kommt, also es ist ja alles noch so ein bisschen gerade in der Schwebe, aber wenn tatsächlich die Zinsen steigen sollten und das im Iran auch nicht weitergeht, dann könnte es dazu führen, dass auch der Sport dann in näherer Zukunft da vor Probleme gestellt wird, weil eben gesagt wird, ja, das ist jetzt nicht so werthaltig, wie wir uns das gedacht haben. Wir gehen mal lieber in sicherere Anlageklassen. Das wäre eine Folge davon beispielsweise.
Aber es könnte auch umgekehrt sein. Weil diese These, dass der Sport verhältnismäßig unabhängig ist von der Gesamtwirtschaftsentwicklung, die ist schon immer noch stark. Die sehe ich schon immer noch oft und da spricht ja auch einiges dafür. Zum Beispiel das Argument, dass nach Corona eigentlich die alten Level wieder erreicht worden sind oder sogar übertroffen worden sind. Das war ja zwischendurch absolut nicht klar. Es gab die Angst der Bundesligan, nach Corona bleiben die Stadien zu 28 Prozent leer, weil da keiner mehr hingeht und weil sich alle abgewöhnt haben, dahin zu gehen. Das ist in der Form nicht eingetroffen. Da gab es ja interne Szenarien, die waren echt finster. Ist aber nicht eingetroffen. Das heißt, du kannst genauso argumentieren, dass die dann sagen, na okay, da und dort und hier geht es gegen die Werte runter, aber da ist immer noch eine Stabilität drin und dann gehe ich da eher noch rein. Und vielleicht noch ein Satz zu den Bewertungen. Also meine Erfahrung oder meine Meinung ist, jede Unternehmensbewertung ist immer nur vor allem Interessen gesteuert und die wird in dem Moment erst zu einer echten Bewertung, wenn es einen Verkaufsprozess gibt. Also wenn da jemand gegenüber sitzt und der sagt, ich zahle X und der Bündnisneuer sagt, ich will aber Y. So und dann wird eine Bewertung gemacht und dann am Ende einigen die sich irgendwo und dann hast du eine Bewertung, die dann für einen Tag sozusagen gilt. Ja und am nächsten Tag schon wieder andere. Alles andere, was da immer gemacht wird, ist, also ich weiß das ein kleines bisschen, weil wir machen ja jedes Jahr das Nebenthema die Liste der reichsten Deutschen und ich bewerte da jedes Jahr die ganzen großen Familienunternehmen und so weiter. Nicht wie ein Wirtschaftsprüfer, halt wie ein Journalist, aber ich sehe das eigentlich immer, dass die diese Bewertung, da gibt es extremste Schwankungen, je nachdem, welches Modell du anwendest, welche Kernzahlen du nutzt, das sind extreme Unterschiede. Deswegen bin ich immer extrem vorsichtig bei diesem, wir bewerten die Unternehmenssohn, so bewertet. Im Sport würde ich eher sagen, im Fußball würde ich sagen, naja, in dem Moment, wenn so ein Klub absteigt, geht die Wert natürlich runter, klar, weil die Erlöse sinken. Na nur, wie viel das der Fall ist, das ist, finde ich, extrem schwer zu sagen. Das weißt du erst, wenn dann jemand kommt und sagt, ich kaufe den jetzt für einen Abschlag von 50 Prozent oder so, und der kriegt das dann auch, den Deal. Dann kannst du sagen, ja, das ist der Wert. Deswegen finde ich das immer so ein bisschen, da ist schon viel so Finger in den Wind halten und mal gucken, wo es so rauskommt, was uns gerade in unseren Interessen passt. Natürlich werden die Besitzer immer sagen, ist viel mehr wert und die Käufer werden immer sagen, ist viel weniger wert. Völlig klar. Und die Börse hat nochmal eine ganz andere Meinung, wobei ja nicht so viele Clubs jetzt börsennotiert sind. Manche Investoren natürlich klar. Da wäre ich also ein bisschen vorsichtig.
Die Multiples, es wird da quasi immer auf eine Bewertungsgrundlage, beispielsweise den Umsatz oder den Gewinn, wird ein Multiplikator drauf gesetzt und gesagt, das ist ungefähr so viel wert. Sagen wir mal zehnmal Gewinn oder so bei einem Wachstumsunternehmen. Das ist aber auch ein bisschen willkürlich. Und ich glaube, das wird auch dann in Zukunft nicht anders sein.
Ja, aber trotzdem habe ich jetzt immer noch nicht so ganz verstanden, warum so viele Investoren in Vereine oder in Clubs dann eben reingehen. Also das eine ist natürlich Synergieeffekte. Okay, das speichere ich ab. Ich würde allerdings auch sagen, so richtig geklappt hat das noch nirgendwo. Nicht mal Chelsea mit ihren drei Mannschaftsbussen großen Kader hätten sie jetzt hinbekommen. Also könnt euch mal angucken, was der aktuelle Trainer, der von Straßburg kam, da bei Chelsea gerade so macht. Da wird dabei gerade angebetet. Und naja, also ob das so gut geht, da bin ich mir nicht mehr ganz so sicher. Also das ist natürlich das eine. Man kann mögliche Synergieeffekte sehen. Und das andere, das müssen wir völlig ausklammern, ist quasi alles non-monetäre. Also ich will eben Werbung machen für meinen Start oder mein Produkt. Das ist ja klar. Aber alle anderen gehen dann quasi rein und hoffen, dass sie den Greater Fool finden. Also dass sie irgendwann wieder rausgehen können für einen Gewinn. Aber gleichzeitig sind ja irgendwann alle drin und es können ja auch nicht alle gewinnen. Also wir haben den Sonderfall US-Sport noch, da ist auch viel Bewegung reingekommen. Die NFL hat als erste Liga eine 10% Beteiligung für Investoren zugelassen. Dann ging es richtig ab und inzwischen ist der US-Sport aufgeteilt. Aber ehrlicherweise ist der US-Sport auch aufgeteilt zwischen irgendwie 5 bis 8 Playern, wenn man das mal so rausrechnet. Und die sind jetzt halt einfach überall mit so 5, 10% drin und so weiter. Und das ist dann eher, glaube ich, infrastrukturell, weil da kannst du nicht rausverkaufen. Aber wenn wir beim Fußball bleiben, irgendwann wirst du kein greater Fool mehr finden. Und dann verstehe ich das nicht, weil die haben ja auch alle einen Zinsdruck. Also das ist jetzt nur ein Beispiel, aber man kennt halt nicht so viele Zahlen. Aber die City Football Group, die zahlt pro Jahr 73 Millionen Pfund an Zinsen, weil sie eben Fremdkapital reinholen mussten. Und diesen Druck, den haben doch andere Investoren auch. Wir haben ja gerade bei CVC gelernt, die mussten sie auch Fremdkapital reinholen, auch wenn es jetzt ein anderes Thema ist. Aber erklärt es mir, ich verstehe es immer noch nicht.
Soll ich Christoph kurz anfangen?
Ich habe noch einen anderen Punkt, der ist ein bisschen abseitiger.
Fangen du mal an. Ich glaube, die Gründe, die changieren auch mal so ein bisschen. Also es war vielleicht mal zu einer gewissen Zeit stärker diese Wachstumserzählung. Und ich glaube, jetzt geht es ein bisschen mehr in diese Richtung von, was wir jetzt gerade auch schon gesagt haben, Krediten und sicheren Erträgen oder Credits. Also letztlich geht es ein bisschen mehr in die Richtung, wir wollen stabile Zahlungsrückflüsse haben und sehen das so als eine Art Kreditgeschäft, so Infrastruktur nochmal. Also Sport wächst nicht mehr so stark, aber es hat ja immer noch relativ solide, man hat erwartbare Cashflows aus Medien, man kann ungefähr wissen, wie viele Leute ins Stadion gehen. Es ist ein relativ unabhängig vom Gesamtmarkt sich entwickelndes Geschäft. Das heißt, man hat einigermaßen verlässliche Zahlungsströme und das ist halt auch ein Asset, eine Stärke vom Sport.
Das ist quasi das neue Sparbuch, aber funktioniert eben nur so lange, wie der Rückfluss aus den Vereinen größer ist als der Zins oder eben der MCSI World Index.
Ja, genau. Wobei, es ist ja so ein bisschen abgekoppelt davon, dass die Medienrechte nicht unbedingt direkt was mit den Vereinsgewinnen zu tun. Deswegen, ich glaube, das kann man schon unabhängig voneinander betrachten. Und ich glaube einfach, dass das gerade das Narrativ ist, was auch in Zukunft erstmal noch gespielt wird. Also wir werden noch mehr erleben, dass sich einzelne Ligen, einzelne Vereine mehr auf Kredite reinholen und viel mehr schuldenfinanziert arbeiten, als jetzt noch neue Investoren an Bord holen und sich da irgendwie Eigenkapitalfinanzierung machen, oder also neue Private Acquities oder so da reinholen. Ich glaube einfach dort, dass die Nachfrage auch höher ist und so ein bisschen die Fantasie raus ist. Aber das ist nur meine Meinung.
Christoph?
Ich wollte noch einen Punkt reinschmeißen, der glaube ich selbst für noch so abgezockte Investoren ein Stück weit gilt. Das ist Emotion. Ich habe vor zehn Jahren mal eine Geschichte gemacht über Investoren im Fußball und hatte unter anderem telefoniert und weil ich damals zitiert habe, kann ich das erzählen, mit Uts Klassen. Ich weiß nicht, ob euch das was sagt. Uts Klassen war ein deutscher Top-Manager, der war mal CEO von NBW, also einem Energieversorger. Er hat dann noch einiges andere versucht. Er war, glaube ich, schon immer mal bei VW. Ein ziemlich schillernder Typ. Der war dann irgendwann raus. Er hat natürlich klotzig verdient und hat sich in Mallorca angesiedelt oder hatte da eh schon irgendwie Eigentum. Als ich den damals sprach, war der gerade Investor bei RCD Mallorca. Der hat sich da eingekauft, nicht wenig. Ich glaube, der hatte einen zweistelligen Prozentsatzanteil da an dem Club und hat dann auch teilweise im Aufsichtsrat gesessen und glaube ich dann später auch mal die Geschäftsführung geführt. Und dann habe ich mit ihm darüber gesprochen, über sein Investment. Und dann hat er einen Satz gesagt und den titiere ich jetzt mal, warum er das eigentlich gemacht hat. Und dann hätte er natürlich sagen können, weil ihm langweilig war auf Mallorca. Das hat er natürlich nicht gesagt, aber er hat einen Satz gesagt, den fand ich gut. Er hat gesagt, naja, die finanzielle Rendite verspreche ich mir ja gar nicht groß, aber die emotionale Rendite, die ist priceless. Also die kann mir nichts ersetzen. Also die Tatsache, sich da hinzusetzen, in diesem Stadion, bei den Spielen dabei zu sein, mitzuschiebern und gleichzeitig zu wissen, na du bist irgendwie, du bist ein Investor, du bist daran beteiligt. Und ich bin mir eigentlich ziemlich sicher, ich weiß das auch von Leuten, die in der Normalwirtschaft unterwegs sind, die da irgendwie im Fußball sind, die sagen, das ist einfach auch ein Teil der Geschichte. Selbst solche abgezockten Investoren. Fußball ist so emotional und zieht die Leute so dermaßen an, dass das für solche Leute echt ein Mehrwert an sich schon ist. Also ich glaube zum Beispiel, warum ist Abramovic da eingestiegen? Klar, aus Reputationsgründen natürlich, aber der findet das auch geil, da zu sitzen. Ja, allein das, der hat jedes Mal, wenn er da sitzt im Stadion und er wird dann noch gefilmt und er ist der Owner und so weiter, dann ist das die emotionale Rendite. Und die ist enorm hoch, je nachdem, wie die Leute so gestrickt sind. Und das gilt selbst für Leute, die Geld geben an irgendein anderen, also irgendein Investitionsvehikel, wie die auch alle heißen und sich dann, wenn sie zu Hause im Fußball sitzen und Fußball gucken und sie zu Hause im Fußball gucken, sich dann sagen können, ja, ich bin daran beteiligt über den Fond von Schlag mich tot. Ich bin da mit Eigentümer, da macht es noch viel mehr Spaß. Ich glaube, dass das auch, damit geht der Fußball ja auch hausieren, damit gehen die auch an die Leute ran, als Verkaufsargument, als Einstiegsargument. Sie sagen, wenn du bei uns einsteigst, dann bist du ganz tief drin und du gehörst dazu und du bist Teil der Fußball-Community und du kannst dich noch viel mehr über die Erfolge freuen oder über Niederlagen auch ärgern, als du das kannst, wenn du einfach nur Sport-Wetten-Auf-XC-Zuschauern bist.
Da wird einem auch suggeriert, wenn du noch eine Wette abschließt.
Und jetzt wollte ich nochmal sagen, und dieses Segment Sport ist für die Großinvestoren klein. Und natürlich haben die in ihren Portfolien Bereiche, wo die Geld reinstecken, das ist dann sozusagen das Spielgeld für die, wo die sagen, das kann grandios funktionieren. Und da bist du beim Thema wetten. Es kann aber auch die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es grandios funktioniert, nicht so hoch. Aber für mich ist die hoch genug, um das Risiko einzugehen. Und wenn es dann weg ist, ist es weg. Und das spielt auch eine Rolle. Weil der Fußball schon auch, das wissen auch Profi-Investoren, ein Stück weit irrational ist. Ich meine, zum Beispiel der ein Argument bei dem Beitrag von den Kollegen über RB Leipzig bei dem Internet. Freunde waren näher, die hatten halt früher, haben sie halt Spieler raus dem Netzwerk geholt wie Harland, Sorbus Lai und Leimer. Und sei es dann nicht mehr gekommen seit langem. Ja, stimmt, wahrscheinlich, ich kann nicht so beurteilen, aber wahrscheinlich hast du solche Kaliber nicht mehr gehabt. Aber das ist natürlich auch, behaupte ich jetzt mal, auch immer ein bisschen Glückssache. Guck dir an, wie die Vereine grugeln um irgendwelche Jungspieler. Und dann geht es in die Hose. Guck dir meinen Lieblingsverein, erster FC Köln, jetzt haben wir den Elmaler, den vor eineinhalb Jahren keiner haben wollte. Da waren er noch jünger, aber haben sie den in der dritten Liga spielen lassen oder was? Ja, und bei Gladbach haben sie sogar aussortiert. Und jetzt wird er wahrscheinlich, wenn er im Sommer verkauft wird, den ganzen Club für drei Jahre finanzieren. Ja, ein Typ. Und das ist natürlich auch die Irrsinnheit des Fußballs. Das ist eben so, ja, der ganze Fußball ist ein bisschen aus solchen Wetten aufgebaut. Und macht es halt auch so spannend. Weil du hast diese Ausschläge, die du immer mal kriegen kannst, die du bei Bayer oder bei VW in der Form eben nicht hast, wenn du da Aktien hältst.
Ja, ich glaube, das unterscheidet den Fußball auch noch von anderen Sportarten. Zum Beispiel wird ja immer wieder auch in dieser Szene von Moneyball gesprochen, dieser Film über Baseball und dass man alles Datenbasiert, quasi die Spieler verpflichten könnte. Das ist ja der heilige Gral quasi so für Private Equity Investoren, wenn es um Investitionen in den Sport geht. Und das ist beim Fußball einfach komplett anders. Das funktioniert ja nicht. Wie Christoph Krupp als Zeitallmahler gesagt hat, wenn man jetzt, keine Ahnung, Marius Bülter auch noch bei euch da irgendwie noch mit rein nimmt, der hat ja eine ganz gegenteilige Karriere gemacht.
Outs bitte nicht.
Einfach nur Outs.
Couché.
Kommt aus meiner eigenen Stadt, deswegen habe ich hier angeführt. Kommt auch aus Rheine. Naja, auf jeden Fall die... Ich glaube halt, dass man... Also zum Beispiel bei Frankfurt hat man ja am Anfang der Saison auch gesagt, boah, haben die gut eingekauft, das wird ja eine Champions League, also garantiert Champions League. Ja, was ist passiert? Jetzt stehen sie da irgendwo im Mittelfeld. Also das zeigt einfach nur immer wieder, dass Fußball so anders ist als auch alle US-Sportarten beispielsweise, wo man mit einer gewissen Wahrscheinlichkeit voraussagen kann, dass Spieler x, y einen Korb aus x oder y Metern da irgendwie immer trifft. So deswegen glaube ich einfach, ja, das wurde von vielen einfach auch US-Investoren ein bisschen, ja, da wurde das Risiko falsch eingeschätzt in der Vergangenheit.
Ja und gleichzeitig ist es aber so, viele dieser Erfolgsgeschichten, die schreibt der Fußball ja so oder so. Also für Saad El Mala hat es ja kein Investor gebraucht, der reingekommen ist und mit seinem klugen Datennetzwerk gesagt hat, hier behalte den, sondern da hatte der FC einfach Glück. Und der Unterschied zwischen einem guten und einem schlechten Sportdirektor, der liegt im Prozentbereich. Also ein sehr guter Sportdirektor, der trifft 60 Prozent seiner Transfers. Das werden dann Spieler, die eben nennenswerte Minuten spielen. Und einer, den man eher als schlecht bewertet, der trifft 40 Prozent seiner Transfers. Das ist so ungefähr die Range, von der man da im Business zumindest spricht. Das heißt, alles, was man hier quasi suggeriert, also durch Investoren, also klar, du hast dein Geld und kannst einkaufen und kannst aber genauso schlecht oder gut einkaufen wie vorher. Und es hängt auch an ganz vielen Dingen ab, die du nicht kontrollieren kannst, weil Fußball eben einfach so, das macht ja den Fußball so toll, ehrlicherweise. Dafür brauchst du keine Investoren. Und gleichzeitig ist es auch überhaupt nicht planbar, was ja eigentlich, also du hast es jetzt schön rausgestellt, Christoph, warum denn Investoren reingehen, weil eigentlich denken Investoren immer in Risiken und immer in Risikomanagement. Okay, und hier lerne ich jetzt, die Emotionalität führt sie im Fußball dazu, trotzdem reinzugehen. Gleichzeitig ist aber halt auch eine Aufforderung an alle Fans da draußen. Wenn ihr keine Investoren wollt, dann sagt das bitte bei jedem Spiel, weil wenn Dietmar Hopp keine Lust mehr hat, also wenn es für den nicht mehr angenehm ist, an jedem Moment auf der Tribüne zu sitzen in Hoffenheim, weil die Fans protestieren, dann ist diese emotionale Redite vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so groß. Und wir haben es ja auch ein bisschen gemerkt. Also als es diese Banner gab, ich glaube bei Union Berlin damals, Angst Potter, was sich auf Graeme Potter bezogen hat, der eben hinter einem dieser großen Private Equity Firmen stand, die eben einsteigen wollten bei der DFL. Da hat das nach allem, was wir drei so gehört haben, sage ich mal, hat das durchaus von der Reaktion gesorgt. Also dass eben tatsächlich die Investoren dann auch gesagt haben, boah, lohnt sich das hier in die Bundesliga reinzugehen, wenn die Fans ihre Tennisbälle werfen, wenn das so unberechenbar ist und wenn halt einfach die Stimmung so grundsätzlich schlecht ist gegenüber Investoren. Weil, ehrlicherweise, die Investoren haben auch die Bundesliga nicht gebraucht. Die hatten genug andere Ligen und Sportarten, in die sie reingehen konnten. Was aber für mich dann so ein bisschen die Frage aufwirft, ja, wie wird das denn jetzt weitergehen? Also ich möchte mal noch eine Geschichte dazu oder etwas, was jetzt eben gerade sich am Markt entwickelt, mit reinwerfen. Und dann könnt ihr ja gerne mal so eure Einschätzung abgeben, ob das was aussagt. Also wir kennen den Public Investment Fonds von Saudi Arabien. Irre, irre groß. Also schier unermessliches Geld. Und damit haben sie ja auch sich ganz, ganz viel gekauft. Unter anderem mindestens 300 Beteiligungen und Sponsorships im weltweiten Sport. Aber dieser ach so große und endlose Topf, der war auf einmal endlich. Im November 25 soll laut New York Times, dem Public Investment Fund, das Geld ausgegangen sein. Und das liegt auch daran, dass viele der Assets in finanziellen Schwierigkeiten stecken und deswegen schwer abzustoßen sind. Zum Beispiel das ganze Neum-Projekt. Also wenn ihr mal wissen wollt, googelt einfach The Line. Offenbar machen sie jetzt die Line doch nicht. Was das für das WM-Stadion, das es ursprünglich mal in 60 Metern Höhe geben sollte, bedeutet, weiß man nicht, aber das war eh alles immer nur Quatsch. Alles nur Marketing. Aber deswegen hat PEF sämtliche weitere Investitionen gestoppt. Der Kauf von Electronic Arts für 55 Milliarden US-Dollar soll vorerst die letzte Investition im Sportbereich bleiben. Da würde ich als Laie, Jannik, jetzt sagen, ist das ein Zeichen dafür, dass sich die Kaufwut der Investoren langsam abkühlt, der ganze Markt sich beruhigt und dann aber auch manche der Investoren auf ein Problem zu laufen, weil dann eben nicht mehr die Bewertungen steigen und man eben eine Exit-Strategie hat, wenn man wieder Geld braucht?
Ja, also ich sehe das auf jeden Fall so. Bei Saudi-Arabien oder generell bei den Investoren aus dem Mittleren Osten muss man jetzt, glaube ich, sowieso so ein bisschen abwarten, wie sich die Lage da entwickelt. Genau, das war ja quasi der große Topf der letzten Jahre. Aber es war auch schon so langsam, man hat es gesehen, wie du auch gesagt hast, Neon habe ich mir gerade so im Hintergrund aufgeschrieben. Es ist schon seit mehreren zwei, drei Jahren jetzt mit dabei, dass der Ölpreis ja ziemlich unter Druck geraten ist. Also das vergisst man jetzt gerade, wenn man mal an die Tankstätte schaut. Aber es war ja so, dass der Ölpreis auf einem Niveau lag, der einfach gar nicht mehr wirtschaftlich war für diese Region. Jetzt werden natürlich, jetzt sind die Ölpreise zwar hoch, aber Energieanlagen werden gedroht, dass sie angegriffen werden. Und der Tourismus leidet vor allen Dingen. Also das heißt, man muss da so ein bisschen gerade schauen in dieser Region, wo es wirklich hingeht in Zukunft. Und ich glaube, da wird Sport noch mal sehr kritisch beleuchtet werden, ob das wirklich so das große, der große Investment-Case war, oder ob man sich da so ein bisschen auch die Illusion gemacht hat und einfach vielleicht auch mit Spaß investiert hat, was wir gerade auch schon ein paar Mal hatten. Ich erinnere mich auch, ich habe einen Kumpel, der bei meiner großen Unternehmensberatung war und der hat mir berichtet, dass die beim, dass der, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es der PIF war, ich glaube, es war der PIF. Die haben so absurde Projekte bei denen in Auftrag gegeben. Da sollte mal geprüft werden, ob man dort wohl auf dem Busch Al-Arab, glaube ich, Bienenstöcke anbringen könnte, ob man dann nicht Bienen in Saudi-Arabien ja irgendwie züchten könnte. Turns out, konnte man nicht, hat dem Prinzen aber nicht gefallen. Und dann hat der gesagt, dann prüft halt, wie es geht. Und dann wurde halt eine zweite Studie für ein paar Hunderttausend Euro in Aufsage gegeben und dann kam raus, es geht halt doch. Und so ist dann halt das. Ja, das sind solche absurden Geschichten, die dann irgendwie aus dieser Region kommen, wo einfach gesagt wird, das Geld ist egal, macht mal irgendwas. Hauptsache, da kommt eben das richtige Ergebnis raus. Und ich glaube, das wird jetzt ein bisschen abnehmen. Also ich sage irgendwie so ein bisschen verquatsch beim Thema in der Ostern- oder Saudi-Arabien. Aber lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Ich glaube, dass wird tatsächlich so ein bisschen aus dieser Region wird der Geldhahn so ein bisschen zugedreht werden.
Und was bedeutet das dann oder könnte das bedeuten, Christoph? Für wenn, wenn dieser eine Hahn zugeht, geht ein anderer auf?
Ich sehe es gar nicht so so negativ. Ich sehe es eigentlich so, dass natürlich in jedem Markt, der mal so einen Hype erlebt, hast du immer diese Boom-and-Buzz-Phase. Also dann wird es hochgelobt und dann geht es wieder runter. Das geht ja für viele andere Märkte auch. Tech und was auch immer. Bitcoin hast du selber angesprochen. Da geht es in sehr viel kürzeren Zyklen. Ja, alle paar Monate eine andere Story. Aber das heißt, das ist immer auch eine. Gesundung irgendwo. So das Beispiel, das du jetzt gebracht hast mit Saudi Arabien, also diese Staatsfonds, die die zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt viel zu viel Geld hatten und das auch im Prinzip gar nicht vernünftig gemanagt haben, mussten sie lange auch nicht, weil es egal war, weil die einfach mit der Schrotflinte geballert haben im übertragenen Sinne und ein paar Treffer hatten. Es hat gereicht. Das ist halt nicht mehr der Fall. Die würde ich aber nicht als typisch sehen. Die waren schon wichtig für den Markt, aber so eine gewisse Beruhigung könnte auch den Vorteil haben, dass ich bin ja nach wie vor dafür, das will ich noch mal unterstreichen, ich glaube, dass Investoren im Fußball schon helfen können in bestimmten Bereichen. Aber das führt dazu oder könnte dazu führen, dass diejenigen Investoren, die den Sport, den Fußball einigermaßen verstehen und das Stück weit auch besser respektieren als vielleicht andere mit seinen Eigenheiten und trotzdem ein Know-how reinbringen können, was der Branche hilft, zu professionalisieren. Weil die Tatsache, dass die Gehälter so gestrichen für die Führungskräfte, ist ja auch ein Zeichen, dass der Fußball Leute anziehen möchte, die das besser managen können. Und da ist noch viel Luft nach oben auf jeden Fall. Das heißt, die, die es verantwortlich machen, ein Stück weit sind diejenigen, die das verantwortlich machen, ein Stück weit sind diejenigen, die das verantwortlich machen. Also das ist ja das, was die Engländer gemacht haben. Die haben am Anfang auch irgendwelche halbseitigen griechischen Räder gehabt, die Clubs gekauft haben, als sie angefangen haben, die die Anzahl zu verkaufen und haben gemerkt, oh, nicht so eine gute Idee. Und dann haben die Regeln aufgestellt, welche Investoren sie überhaupt haben wollen. Da kann man nicht lang drüber streiten. Die liegen ja bei der DFL auch schon lange in der Schublade, dass man die irgendwann mal rausziehen kann, wenn man die braucht, wenn man eine Mehrheit hat, eine strukturelle. Aber das heißt, diejenigen, die das verantwortlich machen, ein Stück weit die Branche respektieren mit ihren Besonderheiten und trotzdem einen Mehrwert dergestalten mit sich bringen, dass sie Führungskraft, Management-Fähigkeiten mitbringen und dem Fußball dann ein Stück weit helfen, die könnten davon profitieren, weil die werden nicht mehr verdrängt, oder weniger verdrängt von den Irren mit den Geldkoffern. Das könnte eine Folge sein und dann wäre es eine gute Folge. Du fragst aber zurecht, was heißt das für die, die jetzt geguckt haben, ich will eigentlich in fünf Jahren wieder raus. Die müsste ich möglicherweise anpassen. Ob das dann in jeder Hinsicht für die Club so ein Desaster ist, vermag ich gar nicht zu sagen, weil Stück weit sind das ja nur Anteile und Bewertungen. Also wenn die Anteile des Investors am Club an Wert verlieren vor dem Gesamtmarkt, hat das für den Club erstmal keine riesen Folgen, weil der Club macht ja weiter und die Finanzen des Clubs sind ja schon da. Der Bewert ist geringer. Es kann sein, dass der Investor dann vielleicht nicht mehr so Bock hat, sich zu engagieren, blabla, was auch immer, aber zunächst mal ändert es für die Clubs gar nichts.
Vielleicht können dann Genossenschaften sogar die eigenen Anteile zurückkaufen. Das ist ein sehr, sehr großer Schritt.
Genau, das wäre auch eine Möglichkeit.
Ja, wobei man dann, also ich muss sagen, ich habe so ein kleines Störgefühl, wenn immer davon ausgegangen wird, dass teuer bezahlte Manager auch bessere Manager sind. Das ist für mich auch so eine Mehrheit. Aber komplett falsch ist es natürlich auch nicht, weil ich auch weiß, wie in manchen Bundesligaklubs gearbeitet wird. Oder zumindest glaube zu wissen. Und da gäbe es dann schon noch Optimierungspotenzial.
Nein, teurer heißt nicht besser. Das ist schon klar, das ist nicht grundsätzlich besser. Aber es zeigt schon, dass der Fußball sich da große Mühe gibt oder da Leute anzieht und anziehen möchte, die auch aus anderen Branchen Know-how mitbringen, die den Fußball gebrauchen kann. Und da gibt es schon sicherlich noch bessere Besserungspotenzial in vielen Bereichen.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich. Und gleichzeitig muss aber halt, wenn man beim deutschen Markt bleibt, bei den Bundesligisten und Zweitbundesligisten, muss man halt auch die Frage stellen, warum braucht ihr eigentlich Geld? Also das ist ja, glaube ich, auch das, wo externe Manager besser werden. Also der Fußball hat ein Ausgabenproblem. Sie nehmen wahnsinnig viel ein und sie geben ein bisschen mehr aus, als sie einnehmen. Und deswegen segeln sie eben immer so hart an der Kante. Aber eigentlich ist das Geld da, wenn du in die Bilanzen reinguckst, ist immer alles gebunden in Spielergehälter, in Handgelder, in Infrastruktur und so weiter. Also es sieht komplett anders aus, wenn du in einem Verein arbeitest, da hast du das Gefühl, du hast gar keinen Spielraum. Da brauchst du wirklich jetzt den Sponsor, der drei Millionen nochmal gibt, weil dann hast du endlich wieder drei Millionen, die du für irgendwas einsetzen kannst. Aber de facto ist es eigentlich nicht so, wenn man die strategische Position einnimmt, das machen halt die meisten nicht, weil sie nur von Saison zu Saison denken. Von der strategischen Position her ist eigentlich gar nicht so viel Geld gebunden. Du kannst eigentlich noch ganz gut organisieren, weil du hast so einen Fixed Income über Merchandise, über TV-Einnahmen und so weiter und so fort. Der hat eine Variabilität, aber die kannst du ja einpreisen. Wird ja alles gemacht, das ist ja alles kein Hexenwerk. Und du hast Fixkosten, aber an die kann man eigentlich ganz gut ansetzen. Du musst dann nur manche unangenehme Entscheidungen treffen und die wird sich dann eben auf dem Spielfeld zeigen, weil da sind die Fixkosten am höchsten. Und das wollen sie dann immer alle nicht.
Das können wir noch für alle abstellen.
Genau. Aber dafür ist ja dann vielleicht gut, wenn die Manager irgendwann so viel verdienen, dann kann man dann sagen, ja gut, dann entlassen wir jetzt einen Manager. Also die Vorstände, die entlassen wurden beim FC Bayern, also Oliver Kahn, Hasan Salihamidzic und noch ein Dritter war mit dabei, ich glaube Jörg Wacker, haben 16,8 Millionen Euro Abfindung erhalten, laut Handelsregisterauszug, konnte man sich damals runterlegen. Ja, war dann auch einmal teuer. Aber vielleicht könnte man sich auch solche Kosten mal sparen. Gut, aber da will ich jetzt mit euch beiden als Köln und HSV-Fan nicht drüber reden. Das sind nur zu große Wunden, in die wir da nochmal bohren. Habt ihr noch letzte Gedanken? Jannik, hast du noch was, was dir zu dem Thema noch auf der Seele brennt?
Ich bin schon vieles losgeworden. Ich glaube auch, dass, was du sagst, dass Vereine mittelfristig erst mal noch durchlauferhitzer bleiben werden und dass es nicht weniger Kapitalbedarf gibt. Grundsätzlich, also es wird irgendwie weitergehen. Meine Hoffnung ist, dass es auf einem gesünderen Niveau weitergeht. Also eine kontrolliertere Kompetenzialisierung nenne ich es jetzt einfach mal. Also tendenziell irgendwie noch mal mehr Synergien versucht werden zu schaffen. Aber halt auf einer vernünftigen, auf einer vernünftigeren Basis, dass man ja vielleicht versucht, mehr über Schulden zu machen. Weniger über Paradequity, weil das so ein bisschen auch die Freiheit den Verein überlässt und diese Diskussion, diese elendigen Diskussionen, um Investoren im Profifußball so ein bisschen kleiner hält. Dafür müsste man dann halt auch wirklich, was du sagst, Max, man müsste an die Kosten ran. Und ich glaube, das würde dem Sport im Gesamten ganz guttun, auch wenn ich Christophs Position dann auch verstehe, dass man zu Investoren ein gewisses Know-how mitbringen und was dem Sport auch guttun würde. Also wie gesagt, ich glaube, das wird schwierig werden, aber meine Hoffnung ist, dass es gesünder weitergeht einfach.
Du hast halt im Sport jetzt noch eine Besonderheit, da müssen wir jetzt nicht ins Detail reingehen, aber du hast halt einfach dieses weirde Eigenkapital im Fußball. Und dadurch, dass jetzt ja man sich gewisse Grenzen setzt und du ja beim Fremdkapital aufnehmen, dann das Eigenkapital logischerweise eine große Rolle spielt, aber das Eigenkapital eben einfach so seltsam ist im Fußball, weil wenn du einen Spieler kaufst, du dann immateriales Eigenkapital liegen hast, dann sah er, der Maler, der liegt aber noch gar nicht in der Bilanz, weil der kommt aus der eigenen Jugend, verkürzt gesprochen, bilanciell gesprochen. Das heißt, der ist gerade kein Wert, de facto ist er es aber doch. Und das ist natürlich, da verstehe ich auch die Vereine, dass das nicht immer so einfach ist, wie es von Seiten Fans aus aussieht. Also die kriegen halt auch nicht die besten Zinsen, um es jetzt mal sozusagen. Übrigens auch der 1. FC Köln nicht. Da habe ich auch die Bodensee Bank war das doch damals, glaube ich. Aber das ist jetzt nochmal ganz anders.
Die Bodensee Bank hat eine ganz große Rolle im Fußball. Ja, ja, ganz, ganz wichtiger Player. Vielleicht darf ich noch eine Sache am Schluss sagen, Max. Also was ich mir wünschen würde für Deutschland, also ich bin jetzt, ich würde mir wünschen, dass die, dass die, die Liga aus dieser ganzen Investoren Diskussion, die um sie herumtobt, ein Stück weit, die wir auch natürlich hier auch hatten, den Schluss zieht, dass man vielleicht 50 plus 1 hin oder her sich mal überlegen muss, auf Sicht, welche Investoren kann ich mir überhaupt vorstellen, weil die Tatsache, was bei Hertha passiert ist, haben wir ja eingangs drüber gesprochen, mit erst KKR, dann Wintors, dann 777. Zumindest die letzten beiden hätten natürlich nie Investoren werden dürfen. Und zwar nicht aus Sicht von Hertha, die haben erst mal für sich entschieden, was für sie das Beste ist. Verstehe ich. Ja, so viel Kohle und der hatte keine Ahnung, alles gut. Aber die Liga als Ganze ist massiv beschädigt worden, da du ja die ganze Denke über Investoren. Und wenn ich als Liga sage, ich möchte mir diese Option offenhalten, irgendwann vielleicht in irgendeiner Form den deutschen Fußball stärker zu öffnen. Das geht ja möglicherweise auch mit 50 plus 1. Das ist ja nicht. Dann muss ich mir aber Gedanken machen, wie managere ich das als Liga? Welche Regeln stelle ich auf? Welche Investoren möchte ich dann? Wie suche ich die aus? Wie bewerte ich die? Und das würde ich mir wünschen, dass das mal passiert, weil das gibt auch eine ewige Debatte. Da kannst du ewig darüber diskutieren, welche Art von Investoren du zulassen willst. Welche Regeln setzt du denen? Da geht es ja auch um Haltefristen zum Beispiel. Wie lange müssen die engagiert bleiben? Wenn du die Haltefristen lang machst, kannst du Private-Equities schon mal mehr oder weniger ausschließen, weil die gehen dann gar nicht rein, weil denen das zu lange ist. Da kannst du ganz viel gestalten als Liga, wenn du es willst. Und du kannst, wie soll ich sagen, natürlich auch versuchen, in Deutschland sehr schwierig, aber versuchen, gewisserweise Vertrauen zu entwickeln für diese Idee, dass man in irgendeiner Form dritten Zugang ermöglicht in den Fußball. Und das sehe ich eigentlich kaum. Wir haben ja auch diese anderen Player in Augsburg und so weiter. Das ist alles wild west eigentlich. Und das schadet eigentlich dem Fußball, dem deutschen Fußball, viel stärker, weil es durch die Position derjenigen, die komplett dagegen sind, ständig stärkt, tagtäglich. Was hat der Windhorst, die haben doch gejubelt, als er eingestiegen ist, die ganzen komplett Hardcore-Gegner von InterStorm, weil die gesagt haben, na wunderbar, der beweist alle Klischees, die wir immer hatten. Oder alle, das sind ja eigentlich überall Klischees. Und das hat die Liga bisher, meinst du, nicht gemacht. Und das ist ein Riesenversäumnis eigentlich. Die machen das jetzt im Kleinen, indem sie Projekte aufsetzen, internationale Vermarktung jetzt machen, eigene Plattformen ausessen, laufen ja gerade riesen Dinge. Aber das wird so ein bisschen unter der Hand immer gemacht. Und da mal eine Debatte zu führen, um zu sagen, naja, wenn es denn so kommt, wie machen wir das denn dann? Auch vor dem Hintergrund der Wolfsburg-Leverkusen-Kartellamts-Diskussion.
Das ist es.
Das fände ich extrem spannend und möglicherweise auch, auch wenn das auch hart werden würde, aber einen großen Gewinn für die Liga, wenn man da weiterkommen würde, etwas. Und das sehe ich nicht. Und deswegen werden wir auch da drin sitzen bleiben, die wir haben. Dann ist uns auch egal, wie viel im sonstigen Fußball tobt an Investorenirrsinn. Und das da nur immer indirekt betrifft, weil die uns alle Spieler wegkaufen, die attraktiv sind, wie die Liga als Ganze braucht, nicht der Club einzeln. Wenn so ein Al Malhar weggeht jetzt nach England, der jetzt kein fertiger Superstar ist natürlich, wird er wahrscheinlich auch nicht werden. Ich weiß es nicht, aber dafür ist er glaube ich zu beschränkt, aber sportlich glaube ich. Aber wenn der jetzt auch weggeht, ist natürlich ein Phänomen der Typ. Und natürlich cool, wenn er noch zwei Jahre bleiben würde, weil er halt echt coole Sachen macht und die Leute mitnimmt und spektakuläre Tore schießt. Wenn der jetzt nach Brighton oder wo auch immer dahin gehen wird, ist er auch wieder weg. Eigentlich auch schade für die Liga, auch wenn der uns nicht zur WM schießen wird, irgendwann.
Ja, wobei, also ich finde die Frage hochspannend. Ich stelle mir aber auch die Frage, warum eigentlich nie darüber diskutiert wird, wenn Investoren so toll sind, aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Warum haben denn dann nicht alle Vereine außer die Werksclubs 49% ihre Anteile verkauft? Weil das wäre ja möglich. Und es muss ja auch, es gibt ja auch Investoren, die zu weniger als 51% reingehen. Das sehen wir ja gerade im US-Sport. Da sehen wir allerdings auch, dass die Gruppe Arktos 38 Investments hat, in allen US-Sport-Ligen, mit 7,2 Milliarden US-Dollar. Also die sind einfach überall reingegangen. Aber ich finde, das ist eigentlich auch eine interessante Frage, die viel zu selten gestellt wird.
Klar, absolut.
Ja, ich glaube, auf jeden Fall ist eine wichtige Frage. Ich glaube einfach, dass in den Club-Strukturen, man muss sich immer bewusst sein, was passiert, wenn solche Investoren reingeholt werden. Und was wollen solche Investoren, die Anteile halten? Die wollen Macht. Und niemand will sich aber bei diesem Verein da reinquatschen lassen, weil es nun mal auch interessengetriebene Vereine sind. Ich glaube, dieses Abgeben von Macht, das hindert viele daran, dass man da noch stärker Investoren bis zu 49 Prozent reinholt.
Ja, beziehungsweise, also das stimmt und das ist auch ein sehr emotionales Thema. Sehr gutes Beispiel, das sogenannte Weltmarkenbündnis beim VfB Stuttgart und die Aufsichtsratsdiskussion. Der e.V. muss der Aufsichtsratsvorsitzende sein, ist auch richtig so, ist auch meine Interpretation von 50 plus 1. Aber eigentlich haben wir da ja schon genau solche Strukturen. Bei Werder Bremen auch, bei Eintracht Frankfurt auch. Die sitzen halt nur in den Gremien, die wir nie sehen. Also niemand kann auswendig alle Aufsichtsratsmitglieder seines Vereins her sagen. Egal wie groß er als Fan ist. Außer er hat dafür einen besonderen Fetisch, sage ich jetzt mal. Und da sitzen ja diese Investoren schon drin. Und es gibt ja Investoren, die sagen, ey, das reicht mir auch. Ich will ja gar nicht im Daily Business mit dabei sein. Aber ich will schon mitsprechen, wenn wir große Entscheidungen treffen, wenn wir strategische Entscheidungen treffen und wenn wir den Vorstand berufen. Weil da will ich jemand haben, der Kompetenz hat in dem Bereich. Und da gibt es ja eigentlich schon sehr viele Wege für Investoren in den deutschen Sport, in den Fußball, auch in die Bundesliga. Interessant, dass es dann doch eigentlich gar nicht so viele gehen. Und die Bewertung von Werder Bremen, das wäre noch mal ein eigenes Thema. Da ist jetzt gerade wieder jemand reingegangen. Es ist ja schockierend, für wie wenig Geld man bei Werder Bremen einsteigen kann. Wenn ich ein bisschen Geld hätte, liebe Hörer und Hörer, spendet. Nee, macht es nicht. Also macht es nicht deshalb. Macht es aber. Ich werde nicht bei Werder reingehen. Also, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Das hat, wie beim letzten Mal auch schon, sehr große Freude gemacht. Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, vielleicht wird das so eine Runde so einmal im Jahr. Geben wir mal wieder so ein Update. Herzlichen Dank an Jannik Tillar von Kapital und Stern. Vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst.
Danke, Max. Hat Spaß gemacht.
Und herzlichen Dank an Christoph Neßhöver, wie immer. Ich freue mich auch immer richtig, euch zu sehen. Das hat echt Spaß gemacht. Danke dir, lieber Christoph vom Manager-Magazin natürlich. Danke dir.
Sehr, sehr gern. Vielen Dank euch beiden. Hat Spaß gemacht.
Und ich danke natürlich auch euch lieben Hörern und Hörern, denn ihr wisst ja, alles, was wir hier machen, ist nicht von irgendeinem Investor finanziert, sondern von ganz vielen Investorinnen und Investoren da draußen, nämlich von euch. Der Rasenfunk ist paywall, werbe- und sponsorenfrei, weil ich vermute, dass diese Sendung auch Fachfremde, Hörerinnen und Hörer hören, möchte ich nochmal betonen. Keine Werbung, keine Sponsoren, keine Paywall, denn alle drei Dinge sind nicht mit den Werten des Rasenfunks vereinbar. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung da draußen. Wie ihr uns Geld zukommen lassen könnt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de, wenn ihr auf den Unterstützen-Button klickt oder einfach in der Podcast und Video Beschreibung ganz leicht zu finden. Und es geht auch innerhalb von Sekunden. Ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die das schon getan haben. In der Folge möchte ich mich da bedanken bei Patrick E., bei Lenz, zweimal bei Jan, bei Julia und bei Dagobard. Das passt natürlich sehr gut zu dieser Sendung. Wenn ihr Feedback habt zu dieser Folge, sehr gerne unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de Und ansonsten sage ich jetzt an der Stelle auch mal, man kann uns auch auf LinkedIn folgen. Ich glaube, das ist hier die richtige Sendung, um das mal anzusprechen. In diesem Sinne abonniert den Rasenfunk, empfiehlt uns weiter, unterstützt uns sehr gerne finanziell und werdet oder bleibt gesund, bleibt uns gewogen. Bis bald wieder. Macht's gut. Ciao.
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Von Ihnen unterstützt.
Herzlichen Dank.